chair of the District
Council
thank you
counselors and members and guests can I
ask you to remain remain standing for a
moment please I would like to introduce
Reverend K Dyer to lead us in thoughts
before today's meeting and of those
caught up in
conflicts so we remember all caught up
in conflict and pray for a peaceful
resolution today father bless all our
endeavors especially during this meeting
guide us in our discussions Enlighten
our minds in every decision that we make
give us your grace that we may
effectively do our parts as public
servants with dignity kindness and
respect amen
amen thank
you okay I would like to declare this
meeting open if you'd all like to be
seated
right welcome to this for council
meeting um first item on the agenda is
apologies for
absence David are there any apologies
for absence thank you chairman uh
chairperson um yes we have apologies
from councelor Eden and councelor
Fleming thank
you thank you very much
um item two on the agenda is
Declarations of Interest could I have
any Declarations of Interest please um
councelor
rock thank you madam chairperson I
declare an interest in the items uh on
the infrastructure statement it's a um
non-registered interest which I declared
at cabinet uh in the items in respect of
the cycle track from um sou to napton
and the wolston surgery uh and it's the
same declarations as I made at cabinet
thank you chairman
chairperson chair is perfectly
acceptable thank
you uh councelor
guest um it's item 15 the infrastructure
funding statement I help fenny Compton
parish council with their application
I'm not predetermined in any
way thank you very much Council
Adams thank you chair um with regards
item
191 um I'm a approved parliamentary
candidate for the liberal Democrats and
uh appointed parliamentary candidate for
war and lemington liberal Democrats
Association and for that reason I'll be
stepping down from uh from my position
uh for that item thank you very much uh
councelor
[Music]
perella thank you Madame chair item 15
I've also helped laddington Parish
Council El laddington Village with their
um uh ifs applications and also item 191
I um want to declare that I'm the
Parliamentary candidate for the liberal
democrats for straford Don Aon and for
the reason I will not take part in the
debate on this motion and I will leave
the room thank you thank you very much
councelor Groot did I see your hand up
no I beg your
pardon is there any more Declarations of
Interest please no right thank you for
that
um uh item three on the
agenda can I have a proposer please on a
seconder for the minutes of the meeting
held on the 24th of May in the 10th of
July please two post thank you councelor
Groot and second thank you councelor
rice um all in favor of that
please thank you you that is agreed
thank you very
much right item four on the agenda
announcements wanted to let members know
about the Charities I'll be supporting
this year as chair I'll be sporting
statford Cadets they're wonderful
organiz organization who provide
opportunities for young people they
learn skills they learn working as a
team and the seets have a lot of fun
while they're doing it and as uh
councilor R for hased from yesterday's
Trafalga celebration and parade they're
very keen and they work very hard at it
as
well I'll also be supporting the
statford youth Collective which is a
vital in a district like us to provide
young people where somewhere to go
somewhere to meet new people and also to
get the support that isn't always
available and thirdly I'll be supporting
all organizations all over the district
who have fundraised for
defibrillators I know that it's all very
well raising the money to pay for a
defibrillator in your area but there are
always ongoing costs associated with it
and I would like to support
organizations throughout the district
who may need additional help with those
ongoing
costs thank
you now if I was going to
um if I was going to list everywhere and
every visit I've done as chair over the
past uh
few weeks since the last meeting we
would be here till midnight so um and
I'd actually rather get on with the
business of the day just a couple of
highlights uh the mayor myself had a
wonderful day judging the National Youth
Market there are some very talented
business people out there who are just
starting out and um the quality was
outstanding it was an absolutely
wonderful day and apart from a brief
shower it was also dry I have also
attended the RSC AGM and I saw MC Beth
which I thoroughly
enjoyed I've attended several Civic
Services over the district um and I only
got lost once not too bad going for me
I've been to Civic dinners and I've also
been to hear
speakers we had the opening of the
Stratford mop last Thursday and I'd like
to say a very big thank you to Bob
Wilson funfairs for the very generous
donation they have made to the chair's
Charities this
year and I'd also just like to thank
councelor Jenny fagley and councelor Ian
fagley is my deputy and consort they've
taken on several engagements on my
behalf when I've been able to attend and
I really appreciate the support you've
shown me so thank
you right I now in invite the leader
councelor Susan Junior to make any
announcements I have no announcements to
make at this
point uh thank
you um I will now call upon um chief
executive David Buckland to make any
announcements thank you madam chair
person Ju Just just one today uh thank
you and I just wanted to Tribute the
staff for putting on the service Fair
which I know all of you have thoroughly
enjoyed today we we we've sent
invitations out to a number of town and
Parish councils and I think we had 50 to
60 town and Parish councils represented
upstairs as well so I just want to thank
the staff for all the efforts that
they've made thank
you thank you thank you uh David I I
will say it was excellent and I had a
very thoroughly enjoyable two hours up
there so thank you to all the staff
[Applause]
involved thank you
counselors um item five on our agenda
the passing of the former councelor Eric
Holder I have been asked by councelor
Neil Eden who was unable to be here
today to read out a brief
statement I was fortunate enough to meet
Eric many years
ago and he was a big factor in my
becoming a parish counselor and he was
somebody who taught me so much about how
best and what it means to really care
for a local
community that relationship grew and I
was honored to call him my friend he was
a loving and generous man he would help
anybody and gave his time and efforts
even late into his illness setting up
and maintaining the Garden at studly
allotments for sufferers of
dementia he was a proud and brave man
who served for all of us in the British
army his determination and toughness
Shone through as he bravely fought
illness and defied the odds time and
time again all with magnificent dignity
Grace and unjerk and love for his family
and friends that love was reflected by
the large amount of people paying their
respects at his funeral and all who
shared in a moving and at times laugh
out loud funny service that reflected
his wonderful roguish sense of humor he
will be dearly messed we will remember
him that's on behalf of councelor Edam
would any other members like to
speak thank you we will move on item six
on our
agenda oh I beg your pardon sorry I
would just like to move the following
that the council notes the death of
councelor Eric Holder and extends its
sympathy to his family and friends in
their loss to minuted thank
you I item six public
participation in accordance with the
council's Constitution questions may
only be asked when received by the head
of paid service two clear days before
the meeting and I do believe we have two
public
questions please um number one the uh
Professor ston please would you like to
approach
hello
hello sir welcome to the
council you have three minutes to to
speak everyone behind a microphone in
this room room today occupies a far more
important role than anyone in the
National Health
Service because unlike the National
Health Service of which I was a chairman
of most of the difficult
bits there is no Democratic
representation there is a huge
Democratic
deficit and this is not true of local
government and what has happened to your
residents in non-star over the last five
or six years as they've progressively
lost Services a
hospital uh clinics uh Consulting rooms
has been
unrepresented by anyone in our po anyone
in our
governance it is for you and your
colleagues in the County Council to
recognize the consequences of that in
the 21st
century Richard Badger at the very end
of the 19th century great philanthropist
and Brewer um gave a great opportunity
to the people of shipston a hospital and
all that went with that that served them
well for 120 years that's gone
demolished I saw the wrecking ball go
through
myself it went through with no public
consultation it went through with no
planning permission it went through with
no endorsement by the Democratic
agencies of this country whether
District Council or County
Council and it has left a local
community in the south of the county
bereft of their
services and dismayed at the lack of
representation that they've
had I've asked questions of the leader
in this statement here and a preamble
that gives you the background to what
what has gone on but the thing that
shocked me most and I take quite a bit
of
shocking is the way in which we have
been deliberately
misled disingenuous arguments put
forward and generally denied a voice
over the very things that as
taxpayers we all pay for that lack of
accountability has to be brought to the
Democratic ins institutions of shipston
and
warshire and you behind the microphones
represent precisely that I'm grateful
for an opportunity for you to hear this
discussion today thank
you thank you very much do you have a
supplementary question regarding the
answer you've
received has you received the answer
my only supplementary
question is can you I recognize you
cannot
instruct the uh South warshire
University NHS Foundation trust I think
I've got them all in uh it's almost down
the uh particular woke initials that
everyone uses these
days but I do
think shipston
shipston res presidents are looking to
Stratford District Council who represent
them to ensure that their voice is
actually
heard we had 700 people in the most
torrential weather
imaginable uh just over two months ago
marching from the center of the town to
the hospital they are looking to you and
I hope leader you will be able to give
them comfort that someone is listening
to their concerns
and capable of ensuring that their
concerns are addressed that's the
question thank you thank you can I thank
you for your supplementary question and
as somebody who saw the end of oler
community hospital I fully support uh
your commitment to the the the community
hospital in shipston and I will as in
the as I've said in the paper uh will uh
make sure that a consultation is
undertaken that this Council will
respond to that consultation at that
spot that time we will be able to put
forward our full thoughts and we will do
so forcefully thank
you thank you very much um Mr Denny
could I request that you please approach
the table thank you you may also be able
to ask one supplementary
question and you'll have three minutes
to speak on this thank you thank
you chair leader councilors thank you
very much for the
opportunity the situation you have to
understand is that the residents of
shipston and the surrounding Villages
and all the country folk in
between are incensed by this decision of
South warshire Foundation trust to
remove the beds from the Badger and move
them to
um lemington
Spar this is a complete betrayal of what
we had
entrusted to that
organization that
organization
planned to rebuild the hospital because
it had been closed down by a Fire
Authority because of the neglect of the
hospital
previously
they agreed that they would accept the
gift of the purchase of land next door
in order to allow that expansion to take
place they promised us a
hospital they deliberately failed to
apply for government funding at the time
that they were asked
to because and they told me this at the
adult Health overview and scrutiny Comm
were it because they'd already made up
their mind that they were going to move
the beds to
lemington that is incontable having
already made the promise of a hospital
to ships and
oner they say that their priority is
Home Care absolutely wonderful if you've
got the people to be able to do it in
the locations where it needs to be done
45% of our population has now reached
the age of 55 was in 2021 they've only
just published the results okay that's
only going in one direction we need the
support of a local community
hospital there's no recruitment no
training no development no of medical
staff in our area anywhere south of War
foret it yeah we need that local
hospital to be up Skilling Care staff
upskilling local health workers right
that's what's
necessary there are no beds the effect
of this I can tell you a near neighbor
of mine his wife happened to have The
Misfortune of tripping over a watering
can in her
garden was lying in the rain for an hour
with a with a broken hip waiting for the
ambulance why was the ambulance delayed
because it couldn't off off offload its
previous partner at War Hospital why
couldn't it offload its hospit at War
hospital because they couldn't get
Patients Out Of War Hospital in order to
make a bed that is time Mr Denny
okay you want the supplementary question
thank you yes you respons what am I
going to tell my near neighbor because
at present his wife is in war Hospital
not receiving adequate physio not re
receiving Rehabilitation because they
haven't got the beds in the
Rehabilitation Unit in in in lington
Spa so my supplementary question
is what are we going to do about the
lack of the hospital in Limington SP I
can tell you that at the end of the 9
month delay that the ICB has put in
place at the end of the 12we
consultation period South worshire
Foundation trust will have finished
building there
Hospital could I have your supplementary
have left that's what I'm asking okay
well i' allow the leader to answer the
question then thank you can can I as I
said in my in my response I I know from
personal experience uh in oler uh what
the impact of losing our community
hospital was um we I uh personally
appreciated it very much for the care of
my
husband um one of the concerns I have uh
as well as responding to the
consultation which this District Council
will do is to maybe ask for other
information to come forward because one
of the things I want to know more about
is about the number of social care and
Care staff and the training that is is
relevant I also want to emphasize
something that's going to come up in my
District Council Leader's report today
which is that 25% of our district
population now is over 65 and that will
have a relevance to our consultation
response thank
you thank you counselor juned thank you
Mr dinny for taking the time to speak to
council
today
okay right moving on then counselors um
item seven on the agenda is uh state of
the district I invite counselor Susan
juned the leader of the council to
introduce this
report
um Can the officer do you want to kind
of outline the rules uh to the
councilors uh for this
debate thank you
leader regarding the state of the
district debate the leader of the
council sets the form of the debate for
this item under article four of the
procedure rules however the chair of the
council chairs the debate itself in
regard to the normal debate debate rules
that would normally apply so chair the
leader has asked as I understand it that
the item lasts no longer than an hour
broken down as follows uh 10 minutes
read the report and its findings from
the leader first uh five minutes from
the major opposition leader to respond
uh thereafter the debate which you will
chair of course chair and then closing
comments uh by the leader before
reverting to the next agenda
item thank you councelor g Ed thank
thank you um I have listened to many um
District Council leaders reports o over
the years one of the things I want to
say right the beginning is just thank
you to the officers for putting this
together uh because the the information
that we get uh is is really really
valuable really helpful to us in making
um using that information for the
development not over of our council plan
but of our bud
budget at the moment we say we have got
this development of a new council plan
and we do need to address some of the
areas of concern that are in this
report there is also in this report
areas of uh where we must highlight
concerns because we want to develop the
budget for the year
ahead of particular note is the way in
which the population has increased in
this District it went up by
11.8% between 2011 and
2021 the third highest in the W West
Midlands in in the upper half of all
authorities in the
UK an Allied to this was the large
increase in properties in The District
1,568 in the last year ahead
215% above the target set by the core
strategy for
2021-22 there has been a steady increase
in the developments in this District
that has been above the targets for most
years other than the year of coid since
2015 to
16 and as we will hear from a notice of
motion later in this me meeting this has
led to problems it's Le led to problems
with the provision of infrastructure
such as schools and GP
Services indeed when you go back and
look at some of the public comp complt
uh comments that were made in the 2013
state of the district which was given at
a time when the local plan was then
actually in abeyance and there was a
problem um with delivery of services at
that time it is interesting to look look
at some of the public comments that were
made at that time and interesting to be
able to reflect that actually a lot of
those comments have come
about there has been a change in the
cost of acquiring a home in the district
we we have median house prices well
above the warshire and England England
medians with a rise of 46% since
2014 and this has had an impact on the
cost of affordable housing though I
really don't like to call it affordable
housing both to buy and to rent the
definition of affordable is set by
government policy as up to 80% of Market
rates it can be slightly U one way or
the other but it is still clearly
unaffordable for so many and those in
the lower income bracket are the ones
that are affected worse by the house
prizes in this district and that is in
that
report we also have private rents that
are third highest in the West
Midlands and it seems to me that we are
clearly pricing younger people out of
living in this
area ahead of the government rental
Reform Bill a number of landlords are
reportedly giving up on buying on bu
toet ahead of that
introduction and because of a higher
interest rates on bu toet mortgages make
it more difficult to earn a profit they
are getting out
early and this will be an increased
pressure on this Council this next year
we have already been warned that that
that is going to be a pressure we need
to be aware of
it there is a change in the main house
type with detached houses the most
common and above the English uh average
for provision of that type of
house we have here in this Council the
sustainable homes sustainable
communities housing
strategy and that in that document
demonstrates the urgent need for more
affordable housing in that in the
district it's not a new strategy but it
is quite
clear we have a policy of providing for
the delivery of affordable housing
anywhere in the whole District not
restricted to any particular Parish with
only some restricted to a particular
Parish but we have to think again about
some of the things that real people what
what it means to a a
family local needs to be in an area
close to family or existing schools are
not always a primary consideration and
that is not always in the best interests
of the family and the children
involved oler for example and forgive me
for for saying about my particular area
had only 68 affordable homes in 11 years
to the end of March
2022 now it is changing because we've
got the alimur estate and some more
housing are coming on board but just
that is an area that has had with a high
need for affordable housing and yet it
didn't get
it comparison with the 2013 state of the
district which used 2011 figures is is
interesting at that time 11.8% of houses
were social rent in the 10 years since
the increase since then the increase has
been a mere
2.2% as probably because of the right to
buy and other reasons but we are not
clearly keeping up with the need for
affordable housing in this District the
number of private rentals has increased
but only by two 2%
.7% now it's my um understanding and
from reading a lot of
documents that the quality of Housing
and it certainly would you know this is
something that I've experienced has a
great impact on health and well-being so
ensuring that not only we have
sufficient housing uh affordable housing
for everyone that needs it in the
district we also need decent quality
housing and that has to be a priority
for this
Council the patent ter of tenure vary
widely across the
district but it is still really really
concerning that 15% uh 15.6% of
households
8,600 homes were in fuel poverty higher
than the rate of England and a rising
number an improvement since 2010 when
19.6 were per were in fuel poverty but
the recent energy crisis is clearly
having an impact on families and putting
pressures on them and the more recent
2021 census figures seem to indicate
that this is on the rise we have a total
of 573 households in the district living
in homes without central
heating the number of households
suffering from damper mold are
unacceptable in this age so are the
numbers facing the cost of living
crisis the capacity to deliver in
installation inst installations has
proved to be a
problem we are shown by this data in
this report that we have a shift in our
demographics with 25% of our population
over 65 and 15% under
18 that has been a big shift since
2013 when 15.3% were 70 in over we have
significantly fewer children and younger
adults living in the district compared
to both West Midlands and England as a
whole and the only area where this trend
is reversed is in
longm this has an impact on the planning
for the provision of
services it's not only USS that have to
provide that Services we have to work in
partnership with others and the County
Council for example has to increase the
expansion of dienal awareness care needs
and other service provision so we do
need to be able to look at this data and
work with
it the on survey which is not in this
data but which has just come out as a
result of the uh census figures
highlights that some single people over
66 have worrying levels risk levels of
poverty in some areas within our
district County Council figures also
point to data that in 2021 22 11.4% of
children under 16 were living in
relative low low income families and
that this has increased since 2014 to 15
in
2010 we had 10.3% of children living in
families suffering from poverty so it's
not actually improved that much since
2010 other inequality inequalities
include a wide range of pay with 20% of
employees on a gross weekly pay below
£346 and a significant gender disparity
in earnings
if I move on to Crime although the
figures show a low rate of recorded
crime in the year to June 22 there has
been an increase and the updated South
warshire Community safety partnership
plan is of interest it's something that
we need to look at and think about wom
we providing services in this area
particularly in things like personal um
antisocial Behavior increase and drug
related
crime one imp statement in The District
in the report is that there is an
economic imbalance in this District
which we have to address in our upcoming
economic
strategy we we have relied on tourism
related jobs and an important part of
the SE sector but we also have to think
about the the jobs of the future we have
to think about some of the figures that
recently came out from the CBI economics
uh about the look the industries that
will provide the net zero alternative
Technologies of the future thank you
very much
indeed thank you councelor juned um I
will now call upon councelor Sarah Wally
hoggins please uh to
respond I'd like to congratulate
councelor junid for bringing to the four
such an eloquent written appraisal in
Pages 53 63 to 71 of all of the
achievements of the previous
conservative Administration it is clear
the livb Dems have huge boots to fill
the conservatives have thus far been
totally silent on the four-year plan the
lib demems are drafting our incredulity
over its inadequacies are LED bare
between Pages 35 and 62 as there is
scant reference to any of the
significant matters raised in this
appraisal in the libdem plan the
conservatives suggest that your further
rewrites before publication should focus
on these and the needs and facts about
the residents of the entire District
rather than squandering precious
resources on matters that are beyond the
scope and influence of this District
Council this report clearly indicates
that yours and the criticism are
particular members of your cabinet have
made about the conservative time in
office are totally baseless and the
negative comments are merely being used
as a way to mask how intimidated and
inadequate you must all be feeling about
the shocking influence of external
events that have led to you unexpectedly
finding yourselves in charge the key
issue the key issues and targets that
this report refers to are entirely those
set by the conservatives our
achievements are too numerous to mention
but these include the conservatives
ensured that through the use of
compulsory purchase order Powers the
future Aviation function at wellsborne
mountfield Airfield was
maintained the conserv atives ensured
that members of the public could fully
scrutinize the work of the council by
ensuring that they could access a wide
range of Council meetings remotely we
all hope as do our former colleagues
that this will continue and perhaps even
be expanded on as the work of individual
counselors should be as transparent as
possible especially for those that voted
them into office recognizing the
importance of this the conservatives
commissioned and implemented a
replacement of the audiovisual system
for this Council chamber which I hasten
to say had been fully budgeted for
unlike the four figure sum that the lib
Dems have spent on their F first
priority when they came into Power which
was to reconfigure the chamber to the
present adversarial layout the
conservatives budgeted for and completed
the state-of-the-art upgrade and
expansion of the district CCTV
operations the conservative Council
ensured that statford District Council
was a founding partner and member of the
Sherborne recycling board to provide a
sector leading joint materials recycling
center I believe that an invitation has
now been extended to councelor in
shenton when this site is officially
opened later on this month I do hope
that this Council remembers and
acknowledges that it was the
conservatives that brought this to the
four and cannot ever be described as an
achievement made by the lib Dems it is
under the conservative leadership of
this Council that in one year 202 1 to
22 we saw the highest number of
affordable homes completed at
495 which I lay down the gauntlet of all
of you to all of you when I say beat
that the excellent conservative budget
management how very rude you are the con
excellent conservative budget management
ensured that the libdem Administration
has inherited General Financial Reserves
at the same level they were in 2019
the general reserves were not depleted
between 2019 and 2023 despite the costs
and difficulties of dealing with the
coid pandemic across the district the
conservatives group budget for 2023 24
included The Prudent creation of an
earmarked reserve of a million pounds
specifically to put the council in a
position to deal with the potential
consequences of inflation that was done
precisely because it was patently
evident that with Rising interest rates
the disruptive impact on energy markets
of the Ukrainian War and the increase in
the cost of living generally the
council's finances would be impacted by
Rising
inflation despite all of this all of the
libdem councilors decided to vote
against the proposed budget let's hope
for all residents that this was not a m
warning of the caliber of those that
will be budget setting and crucially
spending the Stratford District
residents hard-earned local taxes for
the next four years an advantage that
the debt-free council the lib demems
have now inherited is that it is able to
generate additional income from its cash
balances as a result of the sustained
increase in interest rates to an extent
this will be an extra windfall income as
long as interest rates stay at their
current levels but the new
Administration will need to avoid
becoming overly dependent on it as Neils
prattle writing the said in September
about financially crippled councils
appalling decision making by
byoun counselors undoubtedly lies at the
heart of the worst failures thank you
counselor that is your time can I call
please call for a seconder for this
motion
please councelor grott you are seconding
this thank you um now are there any
members who wish to speak
please uh councelor
rock thank you chairman uh rather like
the previous speaker I thought I might
talk about the report
um uh it's it's just one small point
because we've got a very long meeting um
I just wanted to talk about page 55 and
I think the leader talked about the
future and the prosperity of the
district which I think is uh really what
we're rather here for um and if if you
look at the some of the numbers on here
uh on page 55 business by industry uh
and uh I see we've got Simon perfield
sitting in the back of the room he knows
what a sad anarak I am when I start
looking at numbers um but the these
industry codes are derived from uh
standard industry classifications of the
uh of the businesses involved and those
of us uh that are have have been
involved in the past in the Auto
industry will know that we've got uh jlr
in the district which is a very
important uh business for us and
internationally um which I'm sure is
classified as C manufacturing it's not
really manufacturing it's a very
high-tech business and we have a number
of high-tech businesses in the district
and that indeed as as the leaders
reported is um something we need to
nurture those Hightech businesses and if
if we add those together uh together
this constitutes a very significant
propor to the district and that that is
something to be nurtured and is is the
way forward as I just point that out and
we have to bear that in mind for the
planning that some of these things can
be misleading just as how they're
registered um I just also pointed out
I'm slightly mystified of some of the
supposed facts that uh the opposition
mentioned I'm not quite sure whether
moving the tables around in the council
chamber with everybody's agreement I
thought cost any money at all the only
money that was spent was a result of uh
the change in the AV Equipment to move
in one box and uh as for the council
plan I understood that it was um the
ownership of the whole Council indeed
those who was here four years ago will
remember all being consulted on the
council plan and it was owned by all
members of the council as the
forthcoming council plan will be this
time and everybody's been consulted upon
it and made a number of very useful
interventions by all members of the
council irrespective of party
affiliation and I thank them all for
that thank you
chair thank you councilor Rock uh
councelor
pton thank you
chairperson um uh the leader highlights
uh a number of uh challenges as she
would see them uh challenges are also
opportunities it is true to say there
has been a high level of uh development
and house building um those of us with
long memories and I do include the
leader in that uh will recall that we as
an authority had an underd delivery of
Housing and coming to the current core
strategy process were had our feet put
to the fire by the planning inspectorate
um who had a uh the we of an additional
thing called the C allocations plan just
in case we didn't hit our numbers um and
we have and that has created that has
been a function of the strong economic
growth and that is our biggest
opportunity across this District going
into the pandemic South warshire was the
fastest growing part of the West
Midlands had the highest gva and there
are already signs that South War's
economy is recovering and will reassert
its position as a growth engine for the
West Midlands that is good news for our
residents that provides long-term
sustainable well-paid jobs um in one
part of the report um it's seen as a
risk that one that uh manufacturing is
so big a proportion of the of of our
makeup but that the reason for that it's
skewed by jlr and as we all know jlr is
committed to becoming uh a zero emission
Vehicle Manufacturer and the jobs that
go with that the kind of jobs that will
be created hopefully at wellsborne
Airfield by businesses occupying
alongside the aviation uh for the near
Market opportunities that the University
are things to be welcomed councelor junr
bemon as we all do the insufficient
number of houses that have been built in
this country for the last half century
and South war is not immune from that
and its houses of the right type it's
interesting to know that 74% of houses
delivered over the last decade have been
two and three bed houses uh that that
figure actually surprised me it's higher
than I thought uh because uh there is a
lot of focus on on the detached hous
with the four five bed hous is but
councelor junor comes to the Nu of the
problem and the challenges that will
face this Administration and the rest of
us as
decisionmakers when she talks about oler
the brutal Truth for olster is that
because of its surround being surrounded
by Green Belt There is almost no
opportunity for substantive growth for
affordable housing or any other for that
and that will all bring to us difficult
decisions as we come to a South warshire
local plan what do we do about
development and what do we do for
example about considering the future of
the shape of the green belt um my own
ward has had the direct opposite of
councelor junit's ward in that um
frankly it took a cany because it's not
protected by Green Belt uh and we have
to look forward but I would say there is
lot a lot to be positive in this report
and our focused on housing where it is
true to say that this Authority has been
on an upward trajectory for affordable
housing regardless of its
definition and our economic outlooks are
good so I
would wish the leader to PO also
acknowledge the positives and for us to
look forward and for us all to take
advantage of the opportunities in front
of us thank you thank you
councelor
um councelor bromage
please yeah so I've been on this
District Council now nine years I know
quite a few people regardless of that
party politic probably taken a big ear
bashing off me over those nine years I
came in at a time where we were just
about finished with the current core
strategy I had a massive gripe about the
number of houses that s them took
compared to other areas of the district
as the former deputy leader May well
know he certainly got a very big ear
bashing off me amongst many others about
this what's become apparent is that we
are probably not getting our house types
right in the right areas so when I look
over at s where I live and I've often
asked the figures how many people from s
on the waiting list what sort of
accommodations are looking for what
became blatantly obvious very early on
was for example a lack of single person
accommodation one of the most frequent
things I get as a counselor is someone
coms me I'm sleeping on someone's bed
but I basically got no chance I against
something because the lack of single
bedroom places Home Choice plus as much
as we try hard in the housing department
here to get people housed doesn't really
help that
situation it's not always about looking
at numbers of properties built it's
about what type of housing is built what
type of job opportunities are then going
to follow where those houses are
built so again I referen my own area sou
them as our leader of the council
represents home place as well so we've
had a huge amount of housing built not
just in sou and surrounding Villages as
well but if we look what then job
opportunities have been created in the
same time it's very
disproportionate it means people are
having to travel
AAR then that brings in very pe's e
environmental Pro protocols and their
beliefs what we have now is we can all
go on about the bad I could turn around
State say well since the ward read
jigging it suddenly made my ward which
has traditionally been one of the poor
areas by tacking on some of different
part of Sal them a better off area those
areas of poverty still exist rural
poverty is a main issue and it often
goes under the radar not just nationally
but in this chamber here many of those
old Council Estates still have a lot of
rural poverty that were built in the six
50s 60s we need to pull things like that
along we need we can all criticize the
past but we can't dwell on the past we
have to look forward to the future you
can look all the statistics you want in
the world and they may give you an idea
of a future future but you cannot get
that future unless you carry everybody
in this whole
District that is 3 minutes counselor
that is all I was going to say so please
counselors don't dwell on the negative
today dwell on the positive and the
future thank you uh councelor David
Johnson
please
can I make a comment um about something
which is not in the report there is no
travel to work data I'm I'm advised this
is because the 2021 census asked the
question in the middle of coid where do
you work
now I'm told that our officers are
working on trying to find a way of
rectifying this lack of data um there
will have been increase in h workking
I'm sure but given the amount of new
housing in local Villages and towns some
distance from the major centers of
employment I suspect there would have
been a significant increase in traffic
and I hope this data and its
implications can come forward in next
year's
report thank you counselor uh councelor
Anar
please thank you madam chairperson um I
just wanted to join the leader in
thanking the officers for pulling
together this excellent report and also
concur with councelor pton on his views
um spoken a few minutes ago I would also
just like to put in context the
importance that the core strategy has
played and has resulted in the figures
that we have today but it is also well
worth noting that members um from the
current um Administration and the
previous uh libdem Administration either
abstained or also voted against the core
strategy now if we hadn't had the core
strategy adopted we would have a huge
amount of more houses in our villages in
unwanted places and I think this
confirms the
importance of the work that's already be
done in developing the South warshire
local plan that there are no delays no
delays whatsoever we have to press
forward we need to have policies that
meet the requirements of our
residents but on this occasion it will
fall to most of you to make the
difficult decisions going forward on the
south warshire local plan certainly from
this side of the house you will find us
very much in support of developing a
South warshire local plan and I'd just
like to remind you of what happened all
those years ago when we adopted the core
strategy it was difficult we made
incredibly difficult decisions but we've
also had success out of that so please
bear in mind over the next 12 months or
so as the swlp comes forward it's not an
easy pathway but we will benefit and our
residents will benefit thank you
chairperson thank you counselor uh
councelor in shenton
please thank you madam chair
um in line with what uh ton Council
bromage has just said just want to focus
a little bit on some of the the
positives uh over the last few years and
within the report and in particular I'm
looking here down at just so you can see
page 70 um and we we speak here about
climate change and membership of the
Sherborn recycling board which councelor
Wy hoggins highlighted tree planting
successful implementation of the joint
waste and recycling one 123 plus
Arrangements there's been a lot that has
happened over the last few years a big
part of that and I think Julie Lewis is
was in the room up until recently um was
down to to Julie and her team along with
ourselves on this side of the uh of the
chamber we didn't think in terms of
short-termism when we came up with our
plans for climate change which we've not
spoken about up to now properly or about
the waste contract which again had a
thread of climate change through it we
thought about the future knowing full
well that we may not it's always a
possibility and it it came to pass that
we wouldn't be reelected that's politics
that's democracy and I have no no
problem with
that but the point is we looked beyond
the four years we put all the bricks all
those all those uh stepping stones and
the foundations in place for what you
have today which
is a good level of reserves excellent
level of reserves we are not at
Birmingham we're not one of of these
other councils where we're in any danger
whatsoever and yet through this we've
put over a million pounds into a climate
change fund we put 8 million pound into
the the murf we bought in the one two3
plus system we created a had a
multi-million pound contract where we
bought the war sh Waste Services and
ourselves together so you have an
excellent base on which to project
forward so those are some of the
positives climate change which nobody as
I say up to now has mentioned climate
change is one of the biggest issues that
we face back in
2019 um everybody
said shouted that we would we would
commit to 2030 Etc uh and that we would
be carbon neutral now our carbon our
climate change action plan is
realistic
and no mention of
that we put money aside but that hasn't
been spent yet and we're still waiting
for obviously from yourselves because
you have some forward plan but there's
one there's over a million pounds there
the point about this is that we put
these things in place without thought of
whether we would be here in four years
time thank you celor it's now time for
the lib Dems to step forward and
demonstrate their own leadership thank
youel and be fit to hold office for the
next four years thank
you
uh councelor David Curtis please thank
you chair um councelor shenton thank you
very much for reminding us of the
climate change emergency um I'm sure
you'll be pleased to know that we are
expecting a draft um new climate change
action plan to be before cabinet to look
at in November um because unfortunately
the climate the climate change emergency
action plan hasn't actually been updated
since
2021 and yes you're quite right um we
now have I think it's 1.28 five million
pounds in the climate change
Reserve but it is an emergency and I'm
very glad that you brought our attention
to the fact
that the previous administration hadn't
actually spent very or had spent very
little of that and and we will make
every Endeavor to ensure that we now
actually spend that money or invest that
money wisely rather than just leaving it
in the Reserve I have raised this point
over many occasions over the last two
years in full Council and in overview
and scrutiny I have been pressing for a
mechanism to be able to spend this fund
and to invest it and finally under this
new Administration we are making
progress but thank you councilor shenton
for raising the matter for
us thank you councelor wol
please um I think councelor Curtis has
sort of said what I was going to say uh
you had the opportunity to spend that
1.2 million um and you didn't in fact
you didn't even um set up any meetings
um and it must be very difficult for you
because at County you have your Deputy
leader who doesn't even believe in
climate change so you know um at least
we take note of what climate change is
and are trying to do something about it
thank
you thank you councelor councelor Crump
please thank you just a couple points um
before we start um I thought we're
supposed to be talking about um The
District Council on the state of the
district not the County Council but
councelor of and as you're a county
councelor yourself so you you should
know better about that and another point
before me three minute starts um it's
quite interesting we looked at the IV
and the new changes and when can the
Wally hoggins stood up all you could see
was me so um if you want to change your
name to Cel the Wally
hoggins uh if if you owe K Wally hoggins
some money send it to me in the blue
suit uh if she owes you any money it's
the lady over here so just some teething
problems it'll be interesting so
hopefully that will work next time right
so um
yeah I starting on my three minutes
personally um I did smile when councelor
Curtis talked about drafts in climate
action I thought we're trying to get rid
of drafts to make the houses more energy
efficient but but we'll move on that's
just for you get the CES uh one thing in
the strategy priority five putting
residents and community at center stage
and we saw two great speakers at the
start of the meeting Professor ston
apologies if I got your name wrong and
councelor Denny who spoke eloquently
about this putting residents and
Community Center Stage accountability
and
Communications Swift ICB have not
covered themselves in glory and I find
this frustrating when I'm dealing with
various issues with the
NHS Council Rock and myself had some
issue in southam when the coid
injections were were being brought in
and we were you know we aged
significantly and we're now looking at
at least 50 aren't we now canc than our
youthful looks we had before but I think
we've got to do something about this and
as chair of over and scrutiny we are
bringing the ICB on the 3D of November
and the friends of enen Bader so
hopefully I've got that the name right
so they can put their points forward
we've got to be accountable we've got to
get these people to talk to us we've
also got to communicate and this is
where I think we need extra resources
again this has been mentioned over in
scrutiny and I know the chief executive
has spoken about this uh in the past as
well so we need to make sure we've got
enough resources to communicate
effectively uh with our residents and I
know additional resources are being
brought in to the uh that department but
we've got to make sure we use those
resources wisely and we don't overburden
staff so let's consult on the things
that we really need to consult and then
go into different areas you know CU
residents sometimes are consulted to
death and then they switch off off so
yeah let's pick our battles let's choose
the right ones the other Bader one
obviously is one of the biggest
priorities obviously we've talked about
well Airfield as well but let's let's
let's do it properly spend our money
wisely communicate efficiently
effectively and support our resident and
obviously from the east of the district
we need to make sure that uh you know
everybody's getting their fair share
thank you councelor this is three
minutes I'll started so I'll finish um
we've had our so just summing up so yeah
just making sure we we've uh spend our
resource equally and wisely and fairly
throughout the district thank
you thank you councelor pingon
please um i' I'd like to welcome the
emphasis that the council's making on
climate change I know it's one of the
council leaders big priorities um it it
does need a lot of resources putting
into it and unfortunately over the years
of austerity Council resources have been
cut and cut and cut
but we do need to make it as much
priority within the resources that we've
got and it will not only help with um
reducing car carbon emissions and making
the environment healthier but we should
be able to bring lots of good high-tech
jobs to the district so um uh within the
restrictions that that the council has
um I do I do welcome and hope that we
can make some good progress on fighting
clim climate change in the district over
the next
year thank you do any of the members
wish to speak before I go back to the
leader to sum
up no okay thank you very much um
councilor Susan Junior leader of the
council please can I thank you for uh
your input because um the whole idea of
this uh report this debate is to address
those areas that need to be addressing
addressed in the year or so to come both
in the uh council plan but also more
importantly in the budget and in the
local plan as we move forward uh because
there are certainly areas of concern
that we need to address we when I go
back down to councilor brahic yes you
are right there is a lack of um single
bed houses and that is in the council
home sustainable homes um strategy that
we need to address that and yes there is
a need to address rural poverty and we
do need to councel uh Johnson to look at
the travel to work
data and if I can just say that on the
core strategy I was not actually a
counselor at the time of the last
Council um core strategy uh when which
was in 2016 but I was the leader of the
council in when the former count cons
corporate strategy count core strategy
was adopted I led that one uh as leader
in 1999 so I know very very well about
getting a core strategy through and
standing up in front of an examination
and standing up in front of uh the
public uh to get U movement done that so
um I I I don't know what the
circumstances were about the last core
strategy but I certainly know what the
hard work that goes into getting a core
strategy
through and on the climate change
councelor shenton I actually moved the
emergency motion on climate change here
and then chaired the task and finish
group I did so because I having been a
leader before and then I came back in
that year having been the leader before
I actually set up the local Agenda 21 uh
in this Council we won a national award
for our local Agenda 21 work in this
Council and I wanted to make sure that
um that in the interim years there had
been because so much of it was made
discretionary response to for example
Nation indicators um 165 164 Etc
responding back to government were made
discretionary this council did not
choose to make some of those reports
back so I was very interested in making
sure that we maintained our leadership
in that key area of environment and
climate change and and that is something
that I will definitely uh take on on
board because one of the things that um
the CBI economics recently said in one
of its reports was about the importance
of um consistency on a on a on a policy
and having been account having been in
my professional life involved in the
policy changes to do with the green deal
and the green homes grants I know that
lack of consistency and changing uh
policy what that impact has on jobs as
well as people in their own
homes just to assure you the climate
change fund is now it's in its final
bits of you know getting through the
legals and all that type of thing to
make sure uh we can spend it on the
council's own assets which do need
addressing the the um some of the
buildings and some of the Leisure
centers that we own need to be addressed
to make sure we're not um wasting energy
and that we are addressing climate
change and you will be pleased to know
that there is a community climate change
fund that will be announced very very
soon and councelor Crump communication
absolutely communication communication
communication it is essential residents
need to know that that that we are
working on their behalfs they need to
know everything that's going on in this
Council and they need to know where to
come to when they've got an issue so I
welcome the idea that we should have
more on communication so thank you very
much for all your input into this debate
we will take it Forward because we do
need to deliver um and address some of
these key critical areas there are many
areas of success I'm I'm not uh that
that's what not what we've got to
address we've got to address those areas
where we're still underperforming where
we need to improve over the next two to
three years uh so um thank you very much
for your input and I do appreciate that
and Council passingham I do take on
board the comments that you made as well
thank
you thanks thank you councelor GED um we
have a propos and a second uh for the
report to be noted um all in agreement
please thank you very much uh moving on
to item eight minute 148 audit and
standards code of conduct um I can I
please invite councelor Rice as chairman
of that committee to please report on
this can you turn your microphone on
please councelor
R I propose that the uh contents of this
report be
noted thank you can have a second this
please coun thank you very much um this
item can be
debated oh I beg your pardon I'm so
sorry
um councelor perella has has agreed to
Second it thank you very much and this
item can be
debated um Mar would you like to advise
on rules of debate for the members for
this department this part normal rules
of debate apply chair thank you very
much um are any members who wish to
speak on this
item no that's great then thank you very
much we have a proposer in a second
there are we all agreed for this report
to be noted please thank you very much
item nine minute 1 195 a statement of
community involvement
update um this is from the cabinet
meeting on the 4th of September
uh regarding the update can I invite
councelor coucher to introduce this
report please uh thank you very much
indeed chair um this is a matter of
really tidying up our statement in
relation to how we I think altered our
engagement During the coid period it is
a major opportunity for all of our
Parish councils I think to make
representations about how they relate to
this Council and I would certainly um
urge all members members uh to prompt
their Parish Council if they've got
concerns about planning consultations or
about any other matter then uh this is
the opportunity of making those
representations uh while we consult on
this statement thank
you thank you very much can I have a
second for this motion for this please
uh councelor perella thank you very much
this isem will be
debated um Maria there's no more rules
of debate thank you very much are there
any members who wish to speak on this
matter
please okay then well we have a proposed
and we have a seconder is everyone
agreed that this is noted and and the
reports are
approved thank you very much Council um
item 10 minute 1 198 not to the motion
capitalizing on Military
Talent um this is from the cabinet
meeting on the 4th of September can I
invite councelor juned the leader of the
council to report on this please um this
was a notice of motion um that came to
the council uh and we looked at it um we
noted um that the council was already a
signatory to the Armed Forces Covenant I
believe has been since
2012 so what we we did we looked at um
the the the the things that we needed to
do and we recommended that the council
apply for the Bronze award under the
defense employer recognition scheme and
consideration be given to the
requirements for the silver award this
had not been done before uh but we felt
that that was um Justified but we also
put forward a recommendation that
councilor Dominic Skinner be appointed
as the council's armed forces Covenant
Champion again there hadn't been one
before from the members H and we've we
thought that given the um
the your history with the Armed Forces
as a reservist um with the RAF I think
it is as a reservist uh that that would
be um something that you would recognize
uh and the Council would approve it so
that is for the council to now make a
decision
on thank you councelor GED can I have a
second for this item please councelor
Skinner thank you very much um there you
go was that a shock everybody was it a
shock um this item can be debated in the
normal rules of debate well fine were
there any members who wouldd like to
speak on this matter
please councelor pton thank you
thank you
chairperson do you need a moment
chairperson some
water not
water well most people need that when
they've got to listen to me um I I would
just like to uh uh thank uh the leader
for taking on board through the cabinet
uh the motion brought forward by
conservative members parry and Stanley
and we are we're delighted that uh uh
the administration is taking on board uh
the the uh notice of motion and its
recommendation uh and we're pleased to
see uh councelor Skinner uh as the as
the uh appointed Champion uh it's a
right and proper given his uh uh
connection to the Armed Forces I I do
have a question in relation to councelor
Skinner um who is affectionately known
on this side of the house as the seldom
seen kid um given all of the challenges
in his life how are we as an authority
going to support counselor Skinner um to
be hither known as the seldom seen kid
in uh representing and being the
champion for the Armed Forces because it
is important that Armed Forces members
do get a fair Shake we're not as good as
perhaps our transatlantic cousins in
supporting former members reintegrating
into society and and and being able to
contribute in other ways than through
their their service to their country so
um yes how are we going to support
councelor Skinner in his role thank
you um councelor Skinner will be given
every support that he is needed but
counselor Skinner I I believe uh you
know you are you know have a regular I
don't know whether you would like to
address and just let people know ex
about your reservice
role thank you thank you chair um I'll
start by saying thank you councilor pton
for your offer of support it's it's very
welcome um this motion is particularly
something I'm particularly passionate
about um when we talk about veterans
within our community I think we could be
excused to thinking up um images of
Chelsea pensioners Marching In the senat
half or many of the Remembrance Day
parades that I know councilors in this
chamber have attended um but I am 40
years old and I don't look it being
being referenced as the kid counselor I
will take that thank you very much but I
am an armed forces
veteran um due to the recent conflicts
in Iraq and Afghanistan there's a whole
generation of veterans that are a lot
younger than maybe we're used to
veterans that are now coming into the
workforce with some worldclass skills
and I wholeheartedly support the motion
that per has has brought forward um I am
a RF reservist I'm based at ARF Benson
um and I I was actually at a um an
employers engagement event and I would
invite the the leader of the council to
to come along the next year and I'll
I'll certainly extend that that
invitation um and I was chatting to a
gentleman there who ran an engineering
business um and he made the point that
Armed Forces Personnel a can do
people Armed Forces is a can do
organization and I'd like to think that
this Council certainly shares some of
those ideas I just want to read
something before I finish here it talks
about the Armed Forces Covenant and this
is from the Armed Forces Covenant
website it says the Armed Forces
Covenant is a
promise A Promise by the nation to
ensure that those who have served or who
have served in the armed forces and
their families are treated fairly I
think the key words I want to take from
that a
promise this isn't just something else
another political football that we can
kick around this really matters and it
matters to people within our communities
but it's a promise and i' like to think
that this Administration delivers on
their
promises members of the Armed Forces
do not want charity they just want to be
treated fairly I think that is very much
the spirit of this motion I'm really
honored and humbled to be able to help
this council with the support across
this chamber to deliver that thank you
chair thank you councelor Skinner
councelor
brmes yeah again fully support all this
that's been hopefully going to be accept
today by everybody for those may not
know in sou we have particularly good
links to the military both past and
present and indeed councilor Crum will
turn around confirmed we have we have
had things up until this year where a
parachute who lost his life in
Afghanistan we had the annual stretch
race which didn't take place this year
and I could understand the family's
reasons why we are also when it comes to
that sort of thing actually the only
place in the whole country that has
three military medal winners from the
second world war who actually lived next
door to each other never happened
anywhere else in the whole of the UK
that's the some of the past stuff but
it's also the present stuff so
frequently I've personally been
approached by ex forces people various
ages from the younger Generations in the
more recent conf conflicts older
generations and sometimes they them and
their families don't think they got the
support out there they probably need
that and I think it's not just about
having armed forces Champion we as
councilors as a whole should recognize
as councelor Skin said they don't often
reach out for help and support but
sometimes they actually need it and we
got to keep an eye for those sorts of
signs that that's part of our duties as
well and I think it's great we've got
this but we also have a collective duty
to ensure the health and wellbeing to
any veteran any veterans families any of
those who have lost loved ones in
conflict
of this nature who in the end have done
that so we can actually stand here today
and say what we want Express the power
of democracy because without their
sacrifices whether they gave their lives
or they've come through and survive
conflicts that we won't be we wouldn't
be here so every minute every minute
every hour every day just always have
that at the back of your heads and that
without them we would not be here
now
thank you councelor bromid any other
members wish to speak on this item thank
you councelor
KMP will be very very brief this time
Madam chair personent yeah I think this
is really important my father was C
guards he was out in Palestine in 1948
it's ironic we're talking about
Palestine now 75 years on um and we've
got to learn from this we've got to
support our Armed Forces just like you
say I would hope we've Ed the word
covenant and I I hope cancer skin and
I'm sure he will will give us the
Covenant that he will do his utmost on
this cuz I take this really seriously if
he does need any help from southam K the
bromage who's too too shy too humble to
say it was his granddad was one of those
who won the military medal uh and myself
with my father in the co guards we would
be pleasured to help you more than
pleasure and we've got a great facility
the British Legion home in the glan
house in southam where are some
magnificent veterans they are some
brilliant people of all ages as well I
hen to add so please do your utmost on
this please give us a covenant that you
will do your utmost to help as many
people as possible and if you do need
any help you've got my number thank
you thank you counselor um any other
members wish to speak on this well we
have a proposer and teker um all in
favor
please thank you very much on that right
item 11 please minute
2011 excuse me notice of motions
provision of community Public Access
defibrillators on new developments
impact of solar farm development and
public houses could I invite councelor
coucher to introduce this
um this report please excuse
me thank you very much chair um this is
a composite recommendation on three uh
particular items um obviously the
provision of adequate facilities with
new development is extremely important
and and uh def defibrillators have
become one of those standard things that
we need to be providing so this will
need to go in for discussion um as we
negotiate 106 agreements with developers
in in the future and that's our
recommendation
the second point is in relation to solar
Farms um I think we're all um very much
in favor of promoting renewable energy
and as far as we can clearly solar Farms
are tend to be controversial it's the
thing which everybody's in favor of
until it's in their backyard um and
that's where the difficulties come and
so this is a very complex matter uh that
we will need to consider as part of our
preparation of the South warshire local
plan and that's our recommendation in
relation to that the third element is
also extremely important uh to us
particularly in our rural communities
about um preserving our uh local public
houses um it's something which U my
family is very much involved with and uh
I we will be setting up a a task and
finish group uh to look at how the uh
District Council can uh protect and
promote at these very very important
rural
establishments uh so that I propose that
the recommendation is accepted by this
Council thank you councelor C can I have
a second for this please uh Council Rock
thank you very
much Madam chair uh in in seconding the
motion I believe I should declare a um
non-real interest as a former chairman
of uh a community defibrillator scheme
uh some years ago now I think I should
record that thank you
chair uh thank you yes are there any
members who wish to speak on this
matter goodness um councelor Parry
please thank you madam chairperson um
and may I take this opportunity to thank
you for uh identifying one of your
Charities for supportting
defibrillators um I'm in favor of all
these particular motions and I would
just like to highlight one thing um as a
member of Morton moral Parish Council I
organized a CPR defibrillator training
on Saturday so literally at the weekend
and I would just like to emphasize
there's no point having defibrillators
put into communities unless sufficient
and adequate and professional training
is given you can only use a
defibrillator once CPR has been given by
the um local person so you can you can
go and get this defibrillator but
somebody needs to be administering CPR
so it's a much wider issue and I would
just ask Council to give great
consideration that when you are putting
in defibrillators to new developments
there is a a a scheme put in place for
training the local Villages residents
for CPR training and and and how to use
the defibrillator which is quite simple
because it just tells you what to do but
what I can say is I attended um a
similar training three or four years ago
and it I did need a refresher after
three or four years I just wanted to
make that point and thank you for the
work you're doing for your charity chair
thank you thank you councelor parry um
councelor Wy
hins I don't know where to stand now so
that I'm oh there we go looky you right
um I'd like to thank you all for
bringing to the FL all of these motions
that were brought to us by the
conservatives um but I just want to
place on record here that we are
delighted that Nigel rock is still with
us and de we know that that was really
down to the use of a defibrillator at
the time and I know that our at the time
we were all very concerned about you
you're looking fine Health today and uh
I'm sure we're all we are all utterly
relieved about that
um but I would also like to say this
that the rural communities one of which
I represent will be highly relieved that
there is going to be this research on
the impact of solar panel Farms I think
it's key to ensuring sustainability
within within the area and also uh with
regard to uh pubs throughout our
district currently you know they are the
Beating Heart of our communities I seem
to be continually looking at matters
regarding pubs and Pub closures within
within my rural District they're also
important even Even in our towns as well
and and the loss of a of a good Pub is
always um a matter for for dis for
discontent but I I am hopeful that we
come to a solution so that we are better
placed at uh really preventing these
closures of the beating hearts of our
communities from closing and I'm utterly
gratified that this matter like the
other
is being taken very seriously by our
libdem colleagues thank
you thank you councelor w hoggins c coun
oh goodness councelor pton please I do
apologize
told thank you chair uh
yes um just a request for uh to ensure
that there's some joined up thinking
around the
defibrillator issue uh in my own W but
wford Parish Council has paid for uh the
installation and the maintenance of
defibrillators and it's the maintenance
which is the ongoing cost and it's not
just about a planning obligation um uh
the portfolio holder does need to ensure
that officers develop a policy that
ensures there is uh a dialogue with the
relevant parish and Town Council if it's
on Commercial
premises the operator or owner of the
business park or the premises or if it's
a community space that Community
organization
because it is no point whatsoever
installing a defibrillator that then
can't have its ongoing maintenance so it
is just a plea to ensure and I know that
it might be stating the flipping obvious
but sometimes uh it's worth doing so so
the question of ensuring that not only
are they delivered but there is a
mechanism that the ongoing maintenance
and operation uh can be kept in place uh
and um stay off the V chairperson
I would councelor if you made it easy on
me
always uh councelor shenton please thank
you madam chair person
um I used to be a community first
responder so I was I've got firsthand
experience of defibs and how they work
and
CPR and uh so I do want to throw a few
stats at every everyone CU on this side
everyone knows I like numbers so let's
let's talk a few numbers there's
estimated 100,000 defibs in the
UK but only 30% of those are known to
the ambulance service so that means when
you ring up you may not be getting the
defib that you might need or your loved
ones need because it isn't recorded it
might be further
away we also have the we also have the
situation where this Global survival
rate for out of Hospital CPR and
defibrillation is around about
88.8% which is terrible and in this
country we lag behind the Scandinavian
countries because they invest more in
defibrillators and in training training
is so essential in this there's nothing
to fear from CPR then there's nothing to
fear from the defibrillator it is
fairly simple to
do it just needs
confidence
so immediate defibrillation can double
or quadruple the chances of
survival and in 40% of cases there's a
bystander there
and in most of those cases they don't
know what to
do 9 Minutes the average response time
for category 2 around this area is
currently about 32
minutes I live in a rural area in wooden
Wayne I know that there's in that first
20 minutes it is essential that you
perform
CPR and you defib use the
defib if you're waiting 30 40 minutes
and that doesn't happen the chances of
survival go down
rapidly so I am very much in support of
this um and I have to
say I I'm glad that councelor coucher
has has put this forward but I have to
say that I was alarmed on the 4th of
September at the cabinet meeting there
to hear councelor coucher end this
particular piece with and I quote and if
you really want to listen to this on the
webcast it's at 35 minutes 17 seconds I
have to say in my own Ward frankly I've
got more concerns about litter bins
which currently we don't have any
provision for and I know counselor gr
Groot is taking up my issues well bully
for you
thank you councelor that's three minutes
thank you very
much um councelor bromage
please yeah fully supported of this and
just to give some people a bit of back
background history so in sou it was
actually my older brother that first got
the fibs round s them since then we've
had various others go going along I know
Council Crump has been working with the
local Cricket Club of late to sort sort
to deib up there there was an issue
which has been raised here about
maintenance I actually had firsthand
experience in this back in the summer
the defib at Southern Fire Station
hadn't been properly maintained there
was an incident and if it hadn't been
for somebody else being on site there
that person who needed that def FIB may
not survived luckily there was another
one near Enough by for the people to get
but it does stress the importance of not
only getting these fibs in but also
making sure they
maintained what we have found out at a
later point and and only found this out
as well through talking to my brother
was it's not always who you expect is
responsible for maintaining
these and at that point it sort of
occurs to me that actually we sort we do
need to make sure we always know it's
responsible for the maintenance where we
may You' have thought in the fire
station for example it was the fire
service actually it wasn't
in this case it turned out to be the
ambulance
service that's worth thinking about you
may you may not always realize it's
somebody else's responsibility so as
part of this I would like to hopefully
ask for a bit of common sense that maybe
we as a district council can get a
record of every defib and who is
responsible for maintaining them and
ensuring that they are kept up to date
because I would not want to repeat what
happened this summer ever happening
again because that message L came
through to me as I was just about to go
to do something and I was they were like
who's responsible for it it's not
working as a counselor I'm put on the
spot I couldn't give an answer and when
somebody's life could potentially be at
stake you don't want to be in that
position ever that and that was a hard
one for me that day and I spoke to
councelor Crums our County counselor and
also in his portfolio job there and I
ended up speak to my brother about it
luckily I got a bit more inside
information but not everybody's going to
have access to that information it's
important we keep accurate records and
we keep that in public domain and we
keep these things maintained I think
that's so so important
everybody thank you councilor bromage um
councelor wol
please um thank you chair so um most
most of you will know um uh past
counselor Jill CLE um she runs a company
that teaches people
CPR and teaches people how to use
defibrillators um she uh I've just been
whatsapping her she is more than happy
to come in and do a free session with
you all and teach you all the art of uh
CPR and uh how to use defibrillators if
if you would like that I'm happy to set
that up at a mutually agreed time if you
are happy thank
you that's excellent uh thank you for
that uh councilor rol and our thanks go
out to Jill CLE for that incredibly kind
offer and I have no doubt that many
councilors will wish take her up on that
um councelor rock
please uh just briefly chairman I just
wanted to thank uh the off
the kind thanks uh from the conservative
group for Applause I noticed the liberal
group didn't
Applause
[Music]
uh uh and and thank goodness I hadn't
been attended to by councelor
shenton thank you very
much thank you councelor councelor Jenny
fragle
please yeah that's right um I just
wanted to say a couple of years ago the
Stratford Town Council all its uh local
Ward counselors went out and found every
single um hopefully every single def in
their Ward and then a map was made so I
hope that that map actually that map
probably needs upgrading now but I think
it goes out to all of us as Ward
counselors to get our our uh town
councils and our Parish councils onto
that task to bring that information to
this uh establishment so that data can
be recorded and checked on thank
you thank you councelor FR uh councelor
juned please I I would just like to make
a a request um that the task and finish
group on public houses looks
particularly at the background to um the
three tons in oler because it has a
particular case um that we has been
replicated in other pubs elsewhere that
you might might want to have a look at
so if whoever sets up that task and
finish group could you please look at
the background to that uh and making
sure that that that it's brought back
into Community
use thank you councelor GED councelor
littlewood
please uh thank you chair um I just a a
point of further underlining what's
already been said by councelor shenton
and uh the information uh councelor fry
just point pointed out about the
existing map it is is absolutely useless
and the less the ambulance service knows
about it and I think this Council should
take that responsibility to make it
happen thank you councilor
Ood councelor Harvey
please thank you madam chairperson um in
similar ve to council junor could I
suggest that the task and Finnish group
might like to look at the lion at
tredington and I say that I have no
authority to put their name forward but
it's an instance of a pub that was shut
about six seven years ago
uh it was uh dormant it was refurbished
it opened it closed again it it's opened
again and it's it seems to me that for
the task and finish group to have a
balanced view of those uh pubs that are
in difficulty it might well be useful to
have a case study of a pub at least one
rural Pub that has gone through the
whole Mill and is now running quite
successfully thank you councelor
Harvey uh there's no other speakers I
will ask councelor GA to uh to sum up
please thank you thanks chair there's
really two points I just wanted to to uh
um comment on one is clearly obviously
the ongoing maintenance of Def
defibrillators are very important and so
therefore it is very important to ensure
that we have identified who is going to
be the responsible body going to
continue to look after that going
forward and in many of cases that will
be Parish councils and so therefore
that's another matter that we need to uh
discuss with them and increases the
importance of what we're doing in Parish
councils second point I wanted to make
was in relation to councilor shenton's
comment about litter
bins the only way in which we can
fund facilities such as defibrillators
Lins affordable
housing transport other matters is
through 106 agreements with
developers um it is really important
that in the future we uh we uh increase
uh the way in which we do that to ensure
that we do get the infrastructure that
we need to support new developments uh
and I know that this Administration is
putting a very high uh priority on that
and indeed there is a no submotion about
infrastructure coming on late later on
in the uh in the agenda but on these
specific matters I would endorse you to
recommend these uh these
recommendations and also I would also
highlight the fox Loxley as well as
another great example of the community
have taken on the pub there and have
made a great success of
it thank you very much I have a proposal
and I have a second uh um the
recommendation is that the be noted in
the report approved is all in favor of
that please
thank you very
much item 12 on the agenda uh minute 205
notice of motion impatient review of The
Ellen Badger Hospital shipston OnStar um
so cabinet meeting on the 4th of
September can I invite councelor Kohl's
please to introduce this item thank
Youk you yes um as you um as you say
this was review vied at the cabinet for
September as a result of a motion
brought by by college colleague
counselor per Gaya um the recommendation
is to continue to engage in conversation
with the authorities who have the
ability and control and
responsibility
to look at and hopefully be persuaded to
change their mind and how this directly
obviously they've gone out to public
consultation and uh we can hope that
when that consultation has been carried
out with our input and obviously with
the input of the uh undoubtedly
concerned and many consultants of
shipston who I expect will be taking
part that they will be able to form an
opinion that it would be as well to
continue this service in support of
residents locally um I would like to
recommend that this uh motion goes ahead
I can certainly give you my guarantee
as portfolio holder I will be supporting
it and continuing to Endeavor in
constructive and hopefully resulting
successful conversations with the
authorities involved I do however bear
in mind and I do ask you to to remember
that the services involved are deeply
pressed for funding they are having
their funding reduced by the government
and we must be mindful of that and
hopefully present them with the economic
case they need to continue this service
thank you
chair thank you councelor calls can I
have a second there for this motion for
this
please thank you councelor perala I
appreciate this this item can be debated
members and the normal debate rules will
apply so any members who wish to speak
on this please councilor Bish thank you
you may wonder why counselor from salom
wants to speak regarding
something from shipston it's because it
has a knock on effect what is happening
in shipston knocks on effect to S them
so as highlighted earlier about the
situation about anybody going to that
Rehabilitation Hospital that would have
gone to Ellen Badger that now goes up to
the heath cut that could knock on to one
person say from s from hary from
anywhere where you wouldn't always
expect it when you get to oric hospital
I've had lots of experience there over
the years both personally and through
taking devil CH children there again
when you get to A&E it has a knock on
all these factors that may seem a very
local issue for a small area have a
bigger
picture now as I mentioned earlier I've
got an older brother he he started
training at wari he went on to the old
walls grave hospital to had of
children's services became a paramedic
he was one of the ones when they used to
have the local resp paramedic response
base that sell them so they could get
there before the ambulance service and
say and end up Sav many lives and
keeping people out of Hospital helped
set that up that service was actually
scrapped it then meant say you live in
prize Master to get an ambulance to
somebody from a heart who has a heart
attack to get in their times could never
be met so when you are looking at things
like is and things like that serves was
God it looks great to these people who
are saying it's saving us
money what we should be doing is
turnning around and saying is it really
saving you money for a headline figure
or is it just moving a bigger problem
elsewhere what I do know having spoke to
my brother at length and he nowadays
trains paramedics and that on that is
that he would turn around and say and he
has said to me many a time we as a
council need to get the people in not
just from the trust involved with this
likes to the West Midlands Ambulance
Service we need to start asking them
questions we need to go hard at them
because are they really acting in the
interests of our local residents or are
they just sitting there in a spreadsheet
in an office somewhere and say if we get
rid of this that saves us x amount but
we don't look at the knock on
consequence so when they when they do
things like they're proposing now we
should question and question hard we
should ask them to go before our
overviews and scrutinies give them the
invite let them try and justify it it
should not be for them to dictate this
is happening without
question let them justify how they're
going to resolve the the knock on
effects that is three minutes counselor
let them actually tell us why they have
made that decision
properly thank you
councelor uh councelor pingan
please um I seconded this motion when it
came to the cabinet um I agree with
Council and promit was just said we we
haven't you know we haven't been
consulted properly
um professor ston and counselor Denny
very very eloquently told you about the
situation in shipston and and the the
taking away in effect of our community
hospital that we've had for 120 plus
years um and and without really any
consultation um it was a community
hospital for most of that time in the
end as professor stoen said
lots of the facilities gradually got
taken away and it became a
rehabilitation hospital where lots of
you know people from the whole uh of
South warshire got got put in order to
get them out of the hospital but and get
them home as quickly as possible it
wasn't the real community hospital um in
one of the the many protests there's
been in shipston over the last 18 months
we had the chair of the community
hospital Hospital Association speak to
us she is a doctor in werer where they
have still have Community Hospitals and
there are many benefits for Community
Hospitals um and that is why we're
fighting to preserve the one in
shipston um as has already been said um
in in
2001 uh there were plans passed by this
Council for a fully integrated hospital
um it included it included beds they
seem to be calling something that
they're advocating building now a
hospital and it's not going to have beds
um it included doctor surgery new
medical center and a range of medical
services and a health and well-being
Center this was going to be part of a
fantastic new integrated system um and
as a consequence of that the friends of
Ellen Badger turned 8 £650,000
of of community raised money to towards
a hospital that we thought was going to
have
beds then um maybe 18 months two years
ago they took the the the final beds
away from the old hospital before they
knocked it down but since then this the
experience of local people in shipston
um has been dire they they've been the
impatients have all been taken to war
hospital and they wait and when they're
waiting for Community Care um in in my
own experience of neighbors that I've
got there have been fril and ill people
being sent home within a few days of
having to call 999 and being remitted re
admitted uh in no time at all putting
tremendous strain on the ambulance
services people being stuck in hospital
bed blocking with no home care package
they're
advocating people being discharged
straight to home and that that may be
all very well if they're well uh unable
to cope but most frail people that that
we're talking about well they're not
just frail old people are ill and
they're not oh my was my time up already
oh dear I'm afraid so can't yes um well
can I say the the removal can the
removal of the beds is a drastic
reduction in the Health Service
provision for ships in and the
surrounding area and a service that we
had for over 120 years I I hope that the
the whole Council will will support this
unanimously thank you counselor
councelor dunet
please yeah my my husband had a stroke
um and um was admitted into warik
hospital I spent the whole night with
him in in war Hospital uh came out in
the morning and actually had a fine for
parking because I hadn't thought about
parking prices when I was trying to
support him all night but anyway uh he
was moved into the rehabilitation
hospital uh and um he went downhill very
very rapidly and the main reason was
because of lack of social contact as
much as anything else and the support uh
with everyday ordinary tasks uh just
being able to feed himself um get drinks
go to the toilet etc
etc I was very very fortunate um I had
had a doctor GP in oler who
understood and he recommended that he'
be moved to the then oler Hospital which
was a community
hospital I can truly say that it saved
his life and I had him with me for many
years to come after that uh because it's
not only about the
rehabilitation it's about dignity it's
about social care it's about being able
to speak with friends and relatives come
in to to can kind of you know keep your
spirits up uh and uh it's unfortunate
that oler lost its Community Hospital I
remember pushing beds down the High
Street and trying to make make a an
objection uh to the loss of that
hospital uh we still regret the the fact
that we lost it in oler uh so if
anything that can be done to keep it in
shipston I know what it means thank
you thank you councelor juned uh
councelor Wally hoggins
please the conservative group agree with
the recommendations in this paper as a
brails and long Compton counselor um I
am Keen that a thorough and appropriate
consultation delivers on all of our
resident expectations and needs thank
you
part thank you councelor w hogin
councelor wol
please um thank you
chair uh two points I want to make first
first point is um I sit I I'm not
allowed to talk about County but I'm
going to very briefly I sit on adult
Health overview in scrutiny as indeed
councelor shenton does but I've sat on
it for many many many many years and um
so I've known about the history of um
Ellen Badger um for a very long time and
as um John Denny and Brian ston know and
David passingham knows um I was there
when it was uh being debated um at adult
Health OV and scrutiny and and I have to
say I was incredibly hopeful because I
was also pleading for the
retainment of the nickel unit beds
because both were in danger at the time
um and and sadly the outcome as you know
is is for you and shipston is Alan
Badger going but but I suppose there is
a bright light that Stratford is staying
and the nio unit is staying that that
doesn't help you doesn't help you at all
but two years ago I actually brought a
motion to this
Council uh asking for um asking for the
portfolio holder Joe Barker to take it
to County and to pursue it it um because
of the passion around it and the wanting
of to to keep the beds and and how
important alen Badger was um and uh
councilor Barker rejected that in fact
you as uh uh uh the administration at
the time you actually refused to take it
any further which is very sad you
refused to even debate it at the time
we're debating it now at least we are
open and honest about it and we are
debating it so I think it is incredibly
important that um you know I want to
support these people I've supported them
in the past and I feel very passionately
about about Community Hospitals they are
so so important I've been on adult
social care for such a long time and I
know what it's like I used to look after
older people it's for some people it
doesn't work in their homes they have to
have a hospital bed in a community
hospital where they're taught to be
rehab habilitated it's so so important
they can't some of them can't do it I
had a mother that came out of hospital
and didn't even had forgotten how to
turn the kettle on you need those
Community Hospitals for those simple
things in life so we must go back to to
uh the the ICB or whoever makes these
decisions and push and push and push
because we need to keep the alen Bader
Hospital thank
you thank you counc W uh councelor
Harvey
please thank you madam chair person um I
just wanted to draw attention to one
element uh of this whole
issue the proposals that have being put
forward for the development
Redevelopment of the Ellen Badger
Hospital uh are for the hospital itself
uh and for the wellness center in the
middle of of of the site but it also
includes the rep Redevelopment
repositioning of a new Medical Center
for to house the GPS the GPS
currently I was about to say the GPS
currently live in the particular Center
that was uh built in the 1960s they do
but they don't just live in it they have
to live in a house across the street
because they they the the space within
the existing facility is inadequate um
in that since the 1960s the population
of ships that must have grown by
something of the order of 50% um they
are overstretched there there's a short
of GPS nationally and therefore the the
capacity to increase medical provision
GP provision within shipon is very
difficult um but this Council has a
particular interest I know we don't have
a uh a decision-making power in this
matter that lies with the integrated
care board as I understand matters but
um counselors may remember that in last
year's allocation of sill money we
allocated 1.4 million pounds to to this
uh project generally uh that is not an
inconsiderable amount of money in fact
1.4 million out of the 2.7 that was
available at the time was the biggest
single uh donation if that's the right
way to put it allocation uh that we that
we could not a donation I can
see I take your
point um the biggest single allocation
of the of the whole lot but one of the
conditions for every project that
receives a seal allocation was
deliverability now currently the medical
center is stalled because of cost the
increase of cost between when when it
was first propositioned and and given
the pandemic and everything else has
happened building costs have increased
to the point where the partners have
decided they can't afford to do it the
the point I want to make is that this
Council has made a decision to allocate
1.4 million pounds one of the criteria
for allocating sill money is
deliverability now that I'm I'm simply
pointing to the fact that at some stage
in the future and I won't say how long
that is this Council this Administration
may have to make the decision about
whether they continue to allocate 1.4
million pounds to this project or to say
there are other projects which are
deliverable and which could Merit the
money you really would put the cat
amongst the pigeons if at this stage you
felt the need to withdraw 1.4 mil pound
from this project but I put it to you
it's not beyond the bounds of
possibility you may face that difficult
decision thank you councelor Harvey
councelor Rock please thank you chair um
there's a bit of a theme here I'm just
just picking up here
certainly I think there unan unanimity
opinion that we really want to try and
do something about this but we're not in
control of it we've got you know a car
with a robber steering column here that
you know we've got very limited
influence over it and I think uh
Professor stomp when he when he talked
about this the lack of control we've
got I think what we're talking about
here is a consultation that's going to
be received by the authorities in the
Health Service whether I think you've
referred to the ICB in in the collective
there but in in the hospital authorities
as well now I presume and I had a
whisper in the ear of the deputy
Constable a chief
Constable he's the policeman in this
respect that the the the um that the
Gunning principles will apply I presume
when a consultation is done and when
that consultation comes back and if 400
people walked in the rain I presume
they'll F in that consultation and when
we put our response in which I suspect
will say they've got to do something
about it in a positive sense they will
listen to what's said and just not
ignore it there will be an imperative in
the Gunning principles not to ignore it
and to respond and I'm hoping the
officers will point that out when that
that that that goes in so I would just
suggest that it it's soft power that
will work and I I would I would hope
we're all going to support that and
support the people of the area and in
the south of my ward vast as it is that
a lot of a lot of people go to and are
influenced by the provision of service
in the South thank you
chair thank you councelor Vach councelor
shenton please thank you madam
chairperson just wanted to um
clarify a statement if you like the
councelor rol made when she said that uh
councelor Barker hadn't been supportive
and councel Barker is the chair of the
adult social care and she was the chair
on the day of this meeting when uh uh
the two gentlemen and and forgive me
John dny and Dave not Dave passam
because he's here um forgive me but he
she was the chair and she spoke
supportively to of this and sorry I
didn't say 19 I didn't say that I said
at the last meeting I was very specific
at the last
meeting Joe Barker was share and she's
very supportive as we all are of this I
think it's only fair as Joe isn't here
to put that right
point of
order is it a point of order councelor
I'm not pry too sure it is councilor
Barker was a portfolio holder at the
time she wasn't chair and she rejected
the motion that was brought to Cabinet
by us thank you okay point of order
chair is a point of order or point
explanation I I was very specific I
didn't say I mentioned when she was
portfolio holder I was very specific
Thank you very much counselors
um councelor councelor perella please
thank you Madame chair so as we have
heard the elen badger hospital has
provided care for generations of
residents and there is huge public upset
and dismay a even betrayal over the
recommendations by S warer University
Foundation trust that impatients beds
should be relocated to lemington Spa
following the bed review we which
shockingly has not been made public yet
we already have lost a community
hospital in olster we cannot afford to
lose any more impatient beds in our
district enough is
enough Community Hospitals have been
part of our Health Care system for over
150 years the elen badger has a strong
tradition of care and is highly valued
by local people and this support is
shown through action such as fundraising
and
campaigning Community Hospitals with
impatient beds provide important
Integrated Health Care Facilities as
well as employment opportunities to the
local community we know Community beds
enable most patients to resume
independent leaving more quickly this
means that the loss of impatience beds
at the Helen Badger hospital will only
lead to Greater bed
blocking of acute beds and leading in
turn to longer stays in hospital than
necessary as we heard and in fact this
will result in more cost to the trust as
Council bromich alluded we also request
to the ICB that any public consultation
is wide ranging as possible and that its
criteria and time scale are communicated
effectively and the fundings of the
public consultation must inform any
policy decision as we heard during the
state of the district debate our
district is made up of an older
demographics one of the oldest local a
Authority in by medium age population in
the West
Midlands therefore the provision of a
comprehensive healthc care facility
close to home is essential for our rural
elderly communities the South bisher
University ands Foundation trust
recommendations as they stand will have
a disproportionate impact on the
provision of services in our
district I urge councelor to vote for
the motion and send a clear message to
the integrated care board and to Swift
that the council stands with the
residents of shipstone and surrounding
Villages thank you Madame
chair thank you councelor perella uh
well we have a proposer and we have a
second there um for the recommendation
on page
88 of of your papers can I ask if we're
all in agreement for that
please thank you very much Council uh
members uh we have now been going for
just over two hours I'm going to call
for a 10-minute Comfort break uh because
I also need it too um so if you'd like
take 10 minutes now and be back in the
chamber please by uh 1614 thank
you
uh right thank you counselors we're now
moving on to item
13 minute 252 audit and standards
outside
bodies this is at the audit and
standards committee on the 25th of
September
um can I invite councilor rice please to
introduce this report as chairman of
that committee thank you thank you m
excuse me Madam
chairperson um at the meeting on the
25th of September the Democratic
services manager presented a report uh
which set out the current position
regarding outside bodies and presented
options for how to take the review
forward um there was a discussion um at
the committee meeting
um and which I won't go into here
because it's it's it's in the council
papers there were two
recommendations um the first was that a
working group be formed to review and
monitor outside
bodies and the second was that the terms
of reference for the working group be
delegated to the Democratic services
manager in consultation with the
chairman of the audit and standards
committee I me um so I I commend those
two recommendations to the
council thank you Council rise uh can I
have a second for that please Council
wol thank you very much I'd be happy to
Second and reserve my right to speak
thank you thank you Council wol this um
this item is open for debate would any
member like to speak on this
please no councilor wol would you like
to
speak
I'll say a few words if you like not
allowed to mention
County um no I fully support the two
recommendations thank you very
much thank you councelor wol um we have
a proposal and we have the second there
um are we all agreed with the
recommendations on this thank you very
much
counselor item 14 minute 275
introduction of self-build and custom
house building register
fee um this from the cabinet meeting on
2nd of October can I please invite
councilor coucher to introduce his
report
please thank you chair um this is a
particular problem that this district
has in the way in which we operate this
National policy um we've been very
permissive in relation to self and
custom build and actually set setting up
a register uh to make sure people pay a
charge to go on that register hopefully
will identify precisely uh the actual
demand for this type of development it's
been far too developer Le in the past we
want to make it customer Le by those
people who genuinely want to build uh
their own their own their their own H
their own house um so I would commend
this um to you uh the peer review of
planning that took place last week and I
would like to take this opportunity of
thanking all all parties who took part
in that identified this as a particular
weakness of this Authority and one that
needs urgent addressing so thank
you thank you councelor coucher uh can I
have a second for this please thank you
councelor
rock
um this is the item to be debated I'm
sure you all know the rules of the
debate by now and if not I'm here to
remind you uh would any member like to
speak on this item please uh councelor
pton
please thank you uh chairperson uh are
you all okay now you've had your
10-minute break yes thank you you have
your supply I absolutely do thank you
very much um I I just want to welcome
this because this was the result of uh
considerable work between myself as the
then portfolio holder and councelor rock
and indeed to be fair it was councelor
Rock who first brought the issue forward
around how we manage self-build um so
whilst um it is undoubtedly an area of
weakness as it is for all authorities
because we all understand the looseness
of the legislation wish that it were
else um but it is actually and was a
demonstration of real Cooperative
working between like-minded members
unencumbered by thoughts of political
Point scoring to actually get this point
get this to a point where we do have a
charging structure and if counselor Rock
recalls uh I was probably more ambitious
about the level of charging than he was
in this in this matter so so Q Applause
at least from this side of the House of
councelor Rock if not from that side you
failed to last time so and you failed
again they clearly done with you thank
you
chairperson thank you counselor any
other member wish to
speak no well we have a second we have a
proposer and a seconder um I we all in
agreement please with the
recommendation thank you very much
members um item 15 minute 280 adoption
of the infrastructure
funding and sorry I beg your pardon
infrastructure funding statement 2022 to
2023 this will agenda meet item on the
cabinet meeting on the 2nd of October
could I please invite councelor coucher
to introduce this report
please uh this is the the state going
forward um really outlining how we're
going to deal with uh uh sill and other
other payments uh this Administration
has adopted the uh terms of reference as
set by the previous administration uh
and we are abiding by those rules and
guidelines that we that were set out
there um I would Rec uh and I would
recommend this recommendation to you um
as a way of taking this forward um to
ensure that we get uh this money out to
um particularly to Parish councils um
who are urgently in need of
it thank you councelor cther can I
request a second for that please thank
you very much councelor keesley that's
appreciated and this item is open debate
you all know the rules would any member
like to speak
please councelor pingen please um I
noticed that there was 15 £
59,000 of seal money
unspent uh in this report I was just
wondering um is that the a usual amount
I mean why why wasn't it spent there's a
big need for infrastructure in the
district um and is there a way of
allocating it f as fast as possible with
all all the projects that need
doing councelor C can I ask you to
respond to that please um we will do
absolutely everything we can to make
sure that all of this money is well
spent and and spent as as quickly as
possible because as you say there is a
very very urgent need for uh more
infrastructure right across the
district thank you would any other
member like to speak on this I have a
proposer I have a second there can I
have a show of hands for all in favor of
this recommendation thank you very much
councilors
sorry moving on item 16 councelor
questions we have uh four questions and
answers that have been received and been
circulated uh question one councelor
bromage do you have a supplementary
question please i' certainly
do right first all thank you very much
Deputy leader for your response there
there are a couple of well certainly one
very pressing project that is needed for
the town and that is relation to our
part owned Community Center the gra
Hall and the gentleman sitting next to
you Mr Perks may remember a bit of open
space land that we discussed as well on
that and I think they're suitable
project so Deputy leader would you like
to sit down and have a chat with me and
see what projects we could spend these
funds potentially on for sell them
councelor
Rock respond please uh thank you
councelor bromage I thank him for his
original question is
supplementary uh historically speaking
the the grain served the former San
rural District Council from whom it was
inherited from stat uh and it was
inherited by statford District Council
in
1974 the area the southern Ral District
Council 22% of the present
District recently the district council
spent 4 million on Capital re Refuge
trucks and 7 million on the uh uh
recycling uh mrf facility which Serv as
the whole District including the soum
area however although this is the case
looking at further ideas such as you've
just mentioned are most
welcome and uh I see you're mentioning
them now but on on 25th of J July this
year I wrote to the district council
members representing the former rural
District Council area offering a meeting
to generate such ideas uh receiving
positive ideas from most and uh that
meeting where we can discuss the ideas
that you've just mentioned including
others uh will be welcome uh and the
chief executive and deputy chief
executive have indicated desire to
support that meeting which I hope will
go forward thank you very
much thank you councelor uh bromy do you
have a supplementary question for your
second I question ra
please so you may think it was a strange
question to ask but it does have a
little bit of seriousness about this and
it's based on some life
experiences so for a lot of people don't
know actually what sort of work I've
ever done in my life and that I've I've
I work as a DJ and I've worked at
several
nightclubs where these s sorts of issues
have come up about um
pronouns I also as a particular per
individual sometimes personally feel a
bit UNC when people call me counselor
prage even now after all these years so
recognize our
difficulties however I feel
uncomfortable with chair person because
it seems very cold to me just a
pointless Point person at the endend I
do agree that we should look at it and
i' prefer the word chair anyway
regardless of who's actually sitting in
there but I think there has to be an
understanding that sometimes pronouns
may sound a bit innocent can we have
your supplementary question please it's
part of the fr the question but it can
be un comfortable thing to talk
about and I think the right thing we
need to do in this council is not
arbitrarily say I want this title I want
that title I want to be referred to this
and that but I would like to ask the
council as a whole is are we willing to
have an open and honest
debate about this and actually the
consequences of pronouns and impacts it
has on other people in our society
because I think sometimes people do not
realize whether it is an impact or not
so are we prepared to actually have a
full open debate or are we just going to
make arbitrary
titles councilor J do you have a
response to that
please um I think equality matters and
fairness matters and that's why I've
asked the Audi and standards committee
to have a look at it so that we can all
gather everyone's views and discuss it
properly and come to a proper Democratic
decision thank you councelor uh question
three councelor Johnson did did you have
a supplementary question please I do
thank
you can I thank the cabinet members for
his reply my concern is that this sits
alongside other changes recently
introduced by the government which
appear to water down or delay the
commitment to achieving Net Zero as
promised in the 2019 general election
could I ask the cabinet member to keep
this in mind as he move into next year
and so we'll be in a position to deal
with the consequences of any further
delay thank you councelor ccher to
respond please I thank uh my colleague
for his uh for his further question and
uh the answer is yes uh we will do
everything we can uh to ensure that
biodiversity is not lost and is
expedited as soon as it possibly can
be thank you
counselor excuse
me and question four please Council
Johnson do you have a supplementary
thank you for the reply my my
understanding over many years has been
that the income from fees should cover
the cost of processing planning
applications it's important that the
Council taxpayers of statford District
are made aware that they have to
subsidize a service to the tune of
nearly £600,000 a year the district
council is not able to use those
resources to improve Services elsewhere
could the cabinet member keep this under
review as he work towards the District
Council budget next year
thank you councelor Curtis responding
please thank you uh thank you councelor
Johnson for that question as well um
you're quite right that the in your
question you also asked about the fees
that fees generated by service are
hypothecated to that
service however the additional
anticipated £500,000 from planning fees
should that be approved will relieve
pressure on other Council finances so
there will be a POS positive net benefit
there um it is of course unfortunate we
we'll all be aware that since 2013
central government has cut Revenue C cut
grant funding to local governments by
50% over that 10year period and the
government has also Frozen fees charged
for planning for the last seven years so
we hope that this will start to make
some difference thank
you
thank you very much for that uh moving
on to item 17 questions for the leader
please know that 30 minutes will be
allowed for questions um with each
Council permitted to speak for no more
than three minutes and may ask no more
than two questions well is already there
um right does anyone have questions for
the leader please H councelor perel
please thank you Madame chair the recent
urn by the Prime Minister about Net Zero
Target s in effect undermines the
ambitious climate change uh plan by this
Council in straford onon District
including investment in better EV
charging infrastructure in collaboration
with our County colleagues and
retrofitting of council's buildings he
also contributes to more uncertainty for
our local businesses which have invested
in Green Technology can the leader
reassure this Council that the
government backwards announcements will
not distract us us from our plan to
reduce carbon emissions and invest in
adapting to the effects of climate
change yes so for I I have been involved
in in climate change and and the next
zero um in many many ways throughout my
career uh I have done uh work on
circular economy uh I've done work on
renewable energies I spent many years
working on making sure that um uh local
government because I worked as a a local
government lers and at one stage I
worked for def defra I worked with on a
project for defra and I've worked with
many other um organizations uh on uh Net
Zero and the the kind of work that needs
to be done at a local level at a local
government level and and within business
so it was with some um you know I didn't
like what what I heard because for many
years the UK has been a world leader on
climate and particularly The Net Zero
the climate change committee uh said
that the UK is off track uh to meet both
the fifth and the sixth carbon budgets U
then that takes us up to
2037 one of the things that we as local
government but also as government have
to do is to enable major infrastructure
change uh because you cannot change stay
the same there was a time in history
when um you know coal mining was a big
big in uh you know big big part of the
economy in this area things have changed
and we're having to move forward so the
government's job and local government's
job is to enable enable major
infrastructure change because in the
long run that actually saves people
money improves Health but it also
enables new businesses to flourish and
that's one of the things that we must
take forward moving the goalpost and I
have personal experience of this in my
profession at short notice with no
consultation does have problem makes
problems for businesses uh one of the
things that we saw within the Energy
Efficiency um sector um they were victim
to various changes with the green deal
and the green homes grants uh one
company that I know of um went BST as a
result of those changes and we got to
take it it take it into account that we
are investing or we are encouraging to
businesses to invest and you cannot then
change the goalpost when you are
encouraging businesses to invest in the
area uh and Delayed Action in the end uh
increases the overall cost of meeting
net zero one of the um when I was um
looking at this um recently uh I was
asked the question recently um was one
of the reports I I saw was the CBI
economics um and um working with the
energy and climate change
intelligence units and they were
absolutely unequivocal that you know we
do have to move forward with this agenda
because otherwise we lose reputation
both
globally with um both with our leaders
and with our investors and we need to
have the investment in this District in
that kind of U that kind of uh area the
independent review of Net Zero also gave
the a firm warning that a stop start
approach to Net Zero policy is not good
for business and it's certainly not good
for customers it's we we have to make
sure that those people who cannot afford
are enabled and supported to afford but
we have to make sure that the business
is able to to move forward um investment
and economic growth is essential in this
sector it's one of the growth areas that
we can have in this area in our district
H and I think you know we we do need to
make sure that we're encouraging that so
thank you very much for your
question thank you councelor juned uh
councelor Holmes
please thank you chair um I was very
interested to hear the leader of the
opposition talk about the role of the
previous administration making the
council meetings more accessible however
we've been left with the legacy of
Council meetings training committees
been wholly accommodating to those who
are past working age or or who can
afford not to work a full-time job I'm
incredibly proud of the makeup of the
new Council elected this may it's far
more young vibrant talented and
inclusive than what the conservatives
have had to offer The District in their
previous 22
years councilor juned do you agree with
me that there should be a survey of
members to determine the best times for
meetings committees and training uh to
best accommodate as many members as
possible we must allow councilors with
work and family commitments to be able
to contribute to this Council and while
the vast majority of our meetings are
held at times only minority of
councilors can attend we will not be
able to capitalize on the great talent
of all our newly elected
counselors
can can can I thank you thank you for
for that input it is it is very valued
and the value you I I do appreciate on
all sides uh the fact that we are now
getting younger counselors in and that
is good for us because it means that we
have have a reflection of all our
residents uh you know on what the our
residents want I will take your concerns
on board I do think we need to review it
I think we need to have a survey of our
counselors to find out what it works for
counselors what works for officers as
well but it we do need to relook at the
way that we have functioned in the past
uh and and consider new ways of working
thank
you thank you councelor juned uh
councelor Parry please
thank you
chairperson um my question obviously is
to the leader um leader in today's
Council papers there are 42 items
highlighted that were achieved by the
previous administration during its last
12 months of office both myself and my
residents are really anxious to
know we're anxious to know what the new
Administration
has achieved as you're now entering your
sixth month of office which doesn't
include the re reintroduction of the
pensioner parking
permits or the various
consultations um that that have followed
work we have done incident I understand
only
34 parking permits have been applied out
of a possible
3,000 qualifying residents I include
myself in that
30,000 um do you think that this
initiative is offering the council
taxpayer value for money in view of all
the setting up
costs thank you one of the things that
we have to do as a as a new
Administration is make sure that we are
looking in depth at the way the council
functions and the way in which policies
are put together
together one one of the things we've
done obviously the local council plan is
something that is done at the beginning
of every four-year um Administration and
it has had to have a lot more thought
put into it this time around because it
we have very different uh views than
perhaps have been the case for the last
20 odd years so we have been you know
making making sure that that council
plan is put together properly and is
fully uh fully um consulted on because
one of the things I believe very firmly
in is that we must consult with people
and communicate with our our
residents we've also obviously taken on
the the local plan and and that is is
still continuing and um that there that
there's a lot of work there as my count
my colleague councelor CER will and
councelor rock uh will uh ascertain uh
and that that we have we've take we're
taking that one forward in my own
portfolio I've actually done quite a lot
of work um and um in the particular area
of climate
change one of the things that was needed
was to do a complete analysis uh an
audit of the council's own property
because that is costing the council a
lot of money in energy cost but it also
is reflected in our carbon
footprint we are have put forward and
are doing a climate change fund that is
going to be split into two parts one is
that it will be one is with proper rules
and um proper kind of um you know about
how the money will be spent by the
council itself on its assets we can't
just have money and not have rules and
regulations on how it will be spent the
other one will be a community climate
change fund and all that is now uh a lot
of work has gone gone on on that I have
to thank uh our officers for that for
the kind of work that that has been put
into
that one of the things that I I've done
is make sure that I have met as many
people as possible who are our partners
because we have to work with them to
take a lot of our agenda
forward I have to say that the I have
had a very good uh Mee had a very good
meeting with the County Council uh
transport people because again transport
is a big part of the climate change
footprint but it is also a big um
delivery service that that we don't
deliver ourselves but we need to be able
to make sure that in our local plan and
in what we uh in our influence that our
our residents have the ability to move
around by public transport or by other
means that that has been extremely um
useful and they are now coming to us
with uh with um working on um a local
approach to the local transport plan
in our area uh and they've given us some
good news about the way that the
transport and the buses will will move
in future so we've got more work to do
there making sure that that that that
that
question our um climate change officer
who was new into the post a and our
Economic Development officer who are new
on into the post have done a tremendous
amount of work uh both working with
businesses because we have taken the
decision that we are going to continue
funding uh the local community the local
um business Hub uh for uh which other
councils in the in the district in the
when warer have decided not to but we've
decided to uh and um we we've also
decided to um to to work with um other
communities with other on other
community initiatives as
well so there's been a lot of
Preparatory work a lot of of of of of
meeting with
those uh people I've attended for
example um various conferences I've take
been to the um the West Midlands
combined Authority meeting which was
extremely valuable and made sure that
the that the chief executive of the West
Midland combined Authority came here to
meet with our chief executive we've had
a lot of that kind of conversation to
find out what really and really can this
District Council a gain from being part
of the a non-constituent member of the
West Middle Inc comb Authority for
example and some of the government money
comes from there so we we've been doing
a lot of exploration of that we've been
talking about um in our doing a lot of
the preparation for our our budget
because one of the things that we're
going to have to do is make sure that
this coming winter people are going to
need a repeat of previous um help and
support on Energy Efficiency uh making
sure that cost of living is addressed a
lot of that work is is being is all in
preparation and will be in the budget so
there's been a tremendous amount of work
uh Gone on and a lot that has been
achieved uh and uh you know I'm quite
happy to go into more detail if you
require chair if I may just okay no that
that uh I did have you want to ask
another question C well I haven't had an
answer to my 34 permit parking permit
um with the greatest respect I did ask I
I I understand there are 34 parking
permits that have been um issued and I
just wondered whether the leader would
like to respond whether she thinks that
is good value for money for the council
taxpayer in view of all the setup costs
and changes to the automatic number
plate
registration can can I just say there
has been no changes to the you know that
that have cost into the anpr that that
is a a Ser that is already exists and
going and the the cost of the um the
parking permits is set to be able to
cover the cost of the of of actually
administering um any any charge a lot of
these things because people have lost
the
service sometimes it's down to
communication with people that the
service is back again uh and um so it
sometimes takes time for people to come
in but this the level of of the charge
has been set at a level that will cover
the cost of any Administration and any
running of the of the U the Ping parking
permit thank you councelor juned
councelor Jenny fagley
please thank you chair um may ask that
this Council examines its approach to
consultation on particularly mediumsized
developments uh to avoid the lengthy is
uh issues of enforcement when residents
expect ations um have not really been
met one of the things um councilor cure
um referred to earlier was the planning
uh review that has been brought in there
was the local government Association uh
and PAs rather um has done the planning
review a report will come from that one
of the things they did pick up on was um
planning enforcement it was an amendment
from myself actually um I can't remember
I did it I repeated it two or three
years running uh in the in the budget uh
about strengthening planning enforcement
because we need it uh but one of the
things they've picked up on in that uh
planning review is that we do need to
relook at um planning enforcement uh and
the way it functions and I can give you
assurances that that will be done thank
you thank you councelor juned um
councilor brumage
please yes um leader your cabinet meet
in September I asked for the costs
involved with the over 66 parking scheme
and it was I was then given a response
by your cabinet member which didn't get
the figures that I asked for it was a
political statement so I actually did
send a bit of a stropp email back well I
said I didn't want political rhetoric I
wanted cold hard facts to this date I
still not had cold hard facts on the
cost of setting up this scheme the Imp
the cost potential cost to taxpayers
nothing you stated at the last council
meeting this was cost neutral according
to your cabinet member there was no
costings done out for it it's going to
be decided by the overviews and
scrutinous committee over the next 12 to
months which is true has it been costed
out if so give me the figures if not be
honest with the public which is
it the cost of the permit has been set
at 50 and it was set at 50 I you're
having a response thank you councelor
the cost was set on the advice of the
officers as being the amount that would
cover the cost of running and
maintaining and policing the parking
permit we've also said that we want to
have a review after 12 months as to how
that's working and I will make sure that
you that that those figures are gathered
and that you will have them thank you
thank you uh councelor GED councelor
hmer
please thank you chair um this is a
question relating to section 106 and S
money um I had a great catch up with uh
the town clerk of oler Town Council uh
recently um who informed me um that oler
should uh kind of the town that I
represent should has been has had money
approved for that um um has had money
for infrastructure spending um approved
um but is currently sat with uh
Stratford District Council um so I'd
just like to ask the leader uh what can
we do as counselors to make sure that
our residents um are getting that money
and seeing the infrastructure spending
um that they so
deserve I will make sure that I speak to
the cabinet member and to the officers
concerned about making sure that that is
is is um is done uh because uh one of
the things that here in oler we've had
for over many many years is the
difficulty of being able to get section
106 on Sil spent in particular olster
but I think what the Town Council has
been asking about is the speed at which
money now now you've got the decision
today on the infrastru infrastructure
funding statement that was gone through
the council today there is in that uh a
reassurance that the C that oler will
now get uh
9,434 uh and 32 as a a result of the
decision that was taken
today thank you councelor juned uh
councelor wol
please uh thank you chair um leader may
I ask um uh assurances for um supporting
some of our local businesses in uh well
not just in straford but everywhere but
uh at the moment I have a little bit of
an issue with a a licensing issue um
which is causing
great uh heartache uh to a business um
um Council CER and I are trying to deal
with it um and I would like to have your
assurances that you will support local
businesses in going forward particularly
those businesses that were hampered
during the coid years thank you can I
assure you that I'm happy to to meet up
on and with the with the um businesses
concerned to find out more about it and
make sure that um that that that their
messages are taken through to the the
right
officers thank you councelor juned uh
councelor pton
please thank you chairperson uh two
questions um I just want to go back if I
may leader to your response to councelor
parry's question um just want to see if
you um would concur with my analysis of
your response steep learning curve six
months to review the position and then
come to exactly the same strategy as the
previous leader of this Administration
in that it is Mission critical that this
Administration engages with key
stakeholders such as the County Council
West Midland's combined Authority other
partner authorities in
warshire private sector the third sector
and all stakeholders um that would seem
to be my analysis am I correct in that I
have already met with all of those
people and I met with them within one
week of becoming leader I've met with u
just about every single one fact every
one that you've mentioned I have been
out and about meeting with businesses
I've met with wari University I've met
with the West Midland combined Authority
I've met with um the business Hub I've
met with just about wari County Council
public transport um you name it I have
had a meeting with them about making
sure that we work closer together a as
uh with it the from this District
Council with all those bodies Because
unless we learn to work together in
Partnership we won't be able to proceed
at the rate that we want to
proceed thank you leader so that's
following the same strategy then okay
second question if I may um in the last
budget um in addition to an extra 50,000
being um allocated for action on energy
uh something I know that is close to the
heart of uh the leader £250,000 was put
put into the budget uh for cost of
living crisis measures uh can the leader
tell me uh since the uh Administration
came into uh into into control of the
council um what the plan is to spend
that money and how many families in this
District have benefited from access to
that £250,000 uh and if the leader can't
give an answer uh can the leader give me
an assurance as to when uh the leader
will be able to bring such an answer to
a full council meeting thank you
I can't kind of give it give the actual
numbers right away because it dates back
before I became I became leader uh but
we're going to need more help this
coming winter one area for example where
we're going to need help is that um low
income tenants uh and I mean tenants
particularly of private uh sector
tenants are going to find find
themselves with higher bills um there
was a has been a decision taken recently
uh to scrap the plans for for the
upgrade of private rented properties uh
by government and that is going to mean
that they're going to have to face
higher costs and higher energy costs
people had thought that this coming
winter uh energy costs would fall they
have fallen a little bit but they're
still astronomically High compared to
what they were and the government um
amount of money that was coming from
government it will well so far we've not
heard that there will be that extra
amount for government from government uh
for this coming winter so Acton energy
and other organizations like that are
going to face a very very difficult
position coming this you know this
winter one of the organizations that I
know of has been face uh has been
funding um complex case workers um and
um some of the stories that are that
that person has told me uh are really
really difficult to hear uh and that's
going to be repeated coming this this
coming winter so yes we're going to need
support for cost of living and um energy
costs coming because it dates before my
time as leader I can't give you the
whole set of
figures I think that no thank you had
your two questions I just want the
commitment that I just want the
commitment that the leader will come
back with some hard some hard
understanding numbers I'm sure that can
be done thank you councelor juned
um councilor bom your second question
please yeah leader recently I attended
the gra Hall stewards meeting with loan
counselor Crump in sou this District
Council is a 50% share in that currently
with the Town
Council very shocked however to find out
that a lot of repair work is needed at
the moment of which I am informed that
there was a commitment for at least half
the cost now having looked at the
figures that Hall isn't going to get
repaired anytime soon unless there's
some serious District Council
intervention there is structural issues
there is issues with heating there is
issues there regarding overall
environmental
efficiency can the leader arrange for
the right people to sit down and
actually talk with the gra St committee
to sort out about what work needs
actually been done and how this could
potentially be
funded I I am happy to make sure that
the that that is taken up and that the
officers consult with you and consult
with the the grain stewards uh to
understand the issue because I I need to
understand the issue and so I will ask
for that to be reported back to
me thank you councelor juned there is no
more questions then I will move on um
councelor I need to raise the three hour
rule oh I beg your
pardon I do beg your pardon I did miss
you yes this will be the last question
thank you councelor shanton my
apologies thank you chair chairperson my
apologies
um the statford line is a a source of
Pride and Beauty in many ways as it cuts
through Cuts away from urban areas and
comes into our beautiful War
uh Area country of
Countryside and it it's not only
beautiful for the countryside but also
for the the stations that line it that
have been filled with flowers under
cared for and in Henley as councelor
rice will know you know we're bringing
uh the volunteers there are bringing
redundant buildings back into
use and I
suppose I wanted to point out that a lot
of this is done by volunteers
and it's not organized by the Stratford
line rail users group but also the
friends of Shakespeare line they bring a
lot of visitors into this uh into this
town so I'm sort of rather rather upset
as I believe uh the chair of the
Stratford rail users group has uh said
in this week's Herald
that council at coucher is referred to
them as our train spotting
friends they are a bit more than our
train spotting friends they're not our
train spotting friends they are the rail
user group so councelor junid it's I
know as a scientist you will understand
what a binary question is all about so I
won't go into any detail on that but do
you agree with Council coucher that the
Stratford line rail users group are just
a group of train spotters or do you
agree with me and this party that the
statford line rail users group should be
congratulated and commended for the
valuable work that they do along the
line bringing stations back into use
ensuring the trains run on
time and I think they and you and uh as
part of that uh obviously that you
disagree with
counsel couches comments of them being R
just a bunch of train spot spotting
friends it's one or the other councel un
it can't be both you either support
counceling coucher or you
don't can I can I just say that I I when
you're talking about volunteers who
helped support um the uh station um
councelor fragile here is one of the key
people that that goes down there on a
regular basis organizing and making sure
that the the flowers are are um as
beautiful as they are uh I don't I think
you come flating because I don't think
it was when when they the talk when they
was when the the comment was made it was
not in reference to the rail users group
at all so what sorry I've got to stop
you there councelor to the response
first because the rail users group were
very specific can you listen to the
response please they they they the
reference was not to the railroad users
group what I have actually um have a lot
of admiration for the rail users group
and all the work that they do and all
the other volunteers as somebody that
organizes volunteers for at least three
charities in oler I know the the they
the strength of the volunteers and how
much that means I want I recommend and
commend all the volunteers
that have managed to keep the the
stations looking as beautiful as they
are and making sure that those rail
services are kept alive one of the
things that um I need to uh you know
work with the with with rail users
groups but others is on some of the key
issues like the keeping the ticket
offices open because one of the things
that in Stratford with the number of
visitors that we get International
visitors to get it's not only about
keeping the station as beautiful as it
is is it's about making sure that we've
got the staff on board on you know
coming in to the uh ticket office to
make sure that our visitors are
welcomed can I make a point of order
please chair I want to make a point of
order is this a point of order a point
of explanation point of order your point
of order councilor bage point of order
is the title of this section is
questions to leader which we should
expect answers we seem to have today and
at the previous council meeting had a
lot of rhetoric and not so much on the
answers can we make sure in future that
we actually have answers please this is
not a point of order thank you councelor
bromage right moving on councilors we've
been now in session for the past three
hours uh based on the time and in
accordance with the Constitution a vote
is needed to continue with the
meeting excuse me unless this vote is
not carried the remaining business will
be considered at a time and date fixed
or at the next ordinary meeting
councilors please can I have a show of
hands to continue with the meeting this
evening uh that is carried thank you
very much moving on to
the um item 18 thank you m u Mo notice
of motion update this is for information
only motions of update um item one
councils for proportional representation
motion
councelor perella yes I will leave the
room now thank you very much
counselor um this motion want to
proposed and seconded will be debated in
Council um this motion will be proposed
by councelor hatch and it'll be seconded
by councelor fragle I invite councelor
hatch please to uh to propose the motion
thank
you thank you madam chair and thank you
officer and counselors for giving the
time for this debate I will be
brief um so we'll hopefully enable
Stratford District Council to join the
25 other councils and be part of the
council's for PR campaign run by make
vote matter and get PR
done one of the crisis we are facing in
2023 is a crisis in democracy it are as
existing first past the post system that
can be blamed in large part for the
following problems
a third of eligible voters in general
elections do not vote and this Rises to
twoth thirds of eligible voters in the
district election which just saw all of
us voted
in it can be blamed for the constant
policy pendulum swinging of a two-party
democracy where policies are based on
short-term gain and government shy away
from long-term infrastructure
projects it can be blamed for not every
vote counting many people people who
have voted all their life have never had
an MP representing them that they have
voted for myself
included it can be blamed for lazy
governments from MPS who are in a safe
seat not having to work for their
votes it can be blamed for not all votes
being equal at the moment in marginal
seats your vote counts for more than if
you in a safe seat and it usually ends
up with our country being ruled by a
minority ity and a parliament that is
narrow and
unrepresentative in 2015 only 24% of the
eligible electorate voted for the
government so much of the country feels
unrepresented disillusioned disaffected
and
disengaged when people feel powerless
extremism and conspiracy Thrive so can
PR help there are strong arguments that
it would PR would create a parliament
that is is a truer reflection of our
country it would increase voter turnout
Western democracies that have a PR
system have on average
77% turnout 10% more than us it would
lead to more collaborative governance
where MPS must reach across the
political divide outside of their tribe
and build policies on consensus with a
more long-term
View and it would therefore go some way
to create a more engaged and fair
Society we the only democracy in Europe
apart from bellarus not to have some
system of PR and it is already used in
Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland and
it should now be extended to
Westminster there are many different
types of PR I'm not here to argue which
one to go for although I'm sure most
people want to keep the existence of a
constituency MP I'm just urging our
district to add to the growing number of
councils who are calling for a more
representative democracy one where every
vote counts and every vote is
equal thank
you thank you uh councelor hatch for
that um councelor Jenny fragle you are
seconding this motion are you reserving
your right to speak until the end or I
second this motion and reserve my right
to
speak thank you uh councelor
fragle my apologies councelor W Hawkins
please
I think that we need to be very careful
for what you wish for or you need to be
very careful what you wish for because
my simple math reveals that the district
council would have would have had a very
different result had proportional
representation being the voting method
for our residents the lib Dems would
have only had 17 seats the conservatives
15 labor four seats greens four seats
and the independent and the UK Reform
Party w seat looking at the written
motions before us I fail to be persuaded
that comparisons with the parliaments
and Assemblies of Scotland Wales and
Northern irelands of the benefits of pro
proportional
representation however this may change
when we've endured four years of the
libdem leadership of this Council thank
you thank you councelor W hoggin uh
councelor junor
please is just that um out of
information that after the second world
war it was civil servants from this
country that went to
Germany to advise them on the form of
proportional
representation that would be introduced
in that country and the reason they did
that was to make sure that the extreme
parties the extreme Nazi party would
never ever got the chance to to be a
dominant party again in power and it was
say it was British civil servants that
went out I'm a Democrat by heart had the
had the voters um said given something
different um you know in this area if
we'd had proportion I would have
actually um abided by their um their
their judgment uh and um I I just think
that the majority far more people need
to be able to be engaged in democracy
engaged and feel that their vote counts
in order that we uphold the the the the
what democracy is all about as probably
the only person in this whole room who's
actually gone from seeing a country move
from a democracy to a dictatorship and
all that that implies and going from in
a country that went from very being very
very reasonable to seeing extremis come
into power that put my family at risk I
want to be able to see that there is a
serious and SE serious debate about
democracy and a proper valuation by
people of democracy and in my view that
means proportional
representation thank you councelor uh
juned councelor
Curtis thank you chair um I think one of
the key differences perhaps between Lial
Democrat values and conservative values
is that I don't feel that liberal
Democrats believe that elections are an
opportunity for
self-preservation I think good
job thank you councelor
rock I I feel that I I I am going to try
and speak for my colleagues but I feel
that the LI Democrats would welcome an
ction that resulted in wider
representation of views from from our
electorate and that those views are more
reflected in the council chamber um
perhaps the conservatives and perhaps
the leader of the conservatives does not
agree that um uh that our residents
views and voting intentions should be
reflected in the chamber but I think on
this side of the house we probably do
thank
you thank you councelor Curtis uh
councelor br
please so we have the time of our
Council we debating about proportional
representation actually concerns me a
little bit with all the important things
we have to do in the district but that's
another story I'll address this Motion
in
particular as somebody who spent a long
time studying politics when as a little
kid I'm well aware of various voting
systems they all have their pros and
cons
so I may remind councils here we did
have a chance back in 2011 to change the
voting system in this country with the
AV vote 67% turnout and it was rejected
because I've just checked it up actually
that's in reason I know that was a form
of proportional
representation so it is a form if you
like it or not thank you councelor do
not shout out of P prop personal
representation as I said there's lots of
different forms and it's been pointed
out there already is from my point of
view at the
moment it's not so much we should be
looking just at electoral reform we need
to look down in Westminster a big reform
we need to look at councils as big
reforms that because what is blatantly
obvious when I speak to people they
don't think the systems working most
people I speak to when it comes to
voting systems at they have very little
interest they're more interested in
getting a system that works to start
with and that system has to start from
Westminster with reform it also has to
involveed council reform at many the
many layers of government over years
that we have put on there whether it be
combined Authority Mayes any other thing
whatsoever and that but people in
general are feeling disenchanted as much
because when they do have elected
representatives
they're not out there with them in the
community they don't engage it doesn't
matter if you're a Paris counselor
District counselor County counselor MP
any sort of elected official the key
part of democracy is when you are that
electorate official you engage with your
people regardless of their political
persuasion what I have found in my time
as a
counselor is that it's not the vot
voting system they're looking at they're
looking what do I do for them how do I
engage them how do I help them and that
actual change and voting system is not
what people's priorities are especially
our levels it's what we can actually do
for
them and it sometimes gets lost that a
voting system is supposedly so good or
so bad now we could use examples of
proportional representation into like
what happens in Israel where you have
more extremist organizations minutes
counselor public governments or we can
use Germany or we could use ours there
is no perfect system remember
that thank you counselor councelor hmer
please uh thank you chair um I'm sure it
will come as no surprise to everyone in
this Hall that a liberal Democrat
counselor um agrees with the principle
of proportional representation um I'd
just like to make a point on uh PR that
often gets missed because it often gets
talked in terms of kind of votes that
don't matter votes you know votes that
don't get cast at all and I would
actually like to make a point that there
were actually in straford on aen
constituency there were nearly 20,000
votes for the conservatives that had
absolutely zero impact on the
representation they get because under
our current system um the only votes
that matter are the ones that take you
one above whoever finish second um the
conservatives one straped on even by
nearly 20,000 votes all of those votes
the vast majority of people who voted
for the conservatives make no difference
in our electoral system system now you
can argue as to whether that's good or
bad but I would say any system where
only 13,000 roughly 13,000 votes out of
electorate of nearly 75,000 has any
impact on the representation they
actually get I would caution that's
probably not a system uh fit for purpose
any
longer thank you councelor hmer uh
councelor Harvey
please thank you madam chairperson um
I'd like to Echo a point that um
councelor bromer made about
stability um that you you actually do
get as as this Council now has with 25
out of 41 members all from one party we
we we can look forward to a period of
four years of stability we might not
agree with your form of stability and
what you propos but at least you will
have your way and in a sense uh the
system we have is an elected
dictatorship uh because once you're in
power once you've got the votes you can
you can promulgate your your program and
and pursue it and good luck to you
because I think that's uh that's
something that our ourl political system
at the moment actually uh provides and
you should enjoy it while you can um
there is no perfect system and people
who Advocate PR it it's it's all all
error is on one side and all good points
are on the other side uh which which we
all know isn't isn't really the case um
I'd just like to point to a few facts
just a few facts um since 1945 I'm it's
a pity um councelor perella isn't here
um as a measure of instability or a
measure of stability whichever way you
want to look at it uh Italy had 69
governments since 1945 69 governments
Belgium another country which has
proportional representation since 1945
has said has had 68 Cabinets Now the UK
even with the faral nature of
20202 has had
16 16 Prime Ministers since 194 45 and
that's what our system actually produces
yes it's got criticisms but but in the
sense of having a strong government with
a clear policy a strong council with a
clear policy uh i' i' I'm all in favor
of of stability and and the first pass
post system uh as part of the the
coalition government libdems insisted
upon uh a uh a referendum on on a
version of of of PR and and frankly the
British people told you what the answer
is 68% 2/3 said on your bike we don't
want it I I think if you put the same
question again you'll get a very very
similar very similar
response thank you councelor Harvey uh
councelor Parker
please thank you chair um the first time
I've spoken and I hope that you'll find
that I'm always brief um I was uh just
thinking while Council hatch was
speaking about my own personal
experience of of voting and uh I've got
a few a few lines on my face so I'm not
going to tell you how old I am but you
could probably guess that I'm not
youthful and uh I voted in every
election that I've ever been able to
vote in in my life at at all levels so I
voted on many many
occasions and I have voted and I voted
and I've never ever voted anyone into
power
except in May I voted myself into
[Applause]
Power what a ludicrous and FAL situation
thank
you
sorry I was still giggling that thank
you counselor Parker um Council
littlewood
please thank you Madame chair I I I have
to say that councelor Harvey has has
taken most of my thunder but uh we'll
move on from that and I won't repeat
what's already been said but I do want
to go back uh to councelor harmer um who
um gave us a very um instructive U uh
statement to Educators with regard to
proportional representation I like uh
the Council of par I I voted at the age
of 18 in the at the first time in a
referendum and that was for join the eec
so um I think I've got a few lines as
well what I would say it doesn't really
matter it really doesn't matter to the
people in this chamber what system we
are elected with we're here to do the
work that we're required to do on behalf
of the electorate whether they voted for
us or they
didn't to come on after being elected
eled and to worry about how much hard
work's involved is
absolutely disrespectful to the electr
now as a scientist and a mathematician
you will know about normal statistical
distributions proportional
representation will always give you a
normal distribution because there's
normal people are lost the whole
population will have extreme views and
they'll have General views and the
problem with this and we see it in
countries that use proportional uh
representation that that for example
Italy that you and sometimes in more
recent years the Netherlands that you
will get a hung Parliament which
achieves absolutely
nothing well give me some proof of your
statement you you nay saying but the
fact of the matter is that's the reality
it's simple mathematics now I I've
already heard a a comment with regarding
to to to the time we're wasting on this
because we could be doing other things
what we say what 25 other councils say
will have no relevance whatsoever
whether the conservatives get reelected
or the labor party get reelected or
otherwise because because once in power
that party will realize that first P the
post will work best for them okay thank
you thank you councelor counselor Rock
please uh thank you madam chair um some
of you may be old enough to remember I
contested the 2010 election against
Jeremy Wright and the very first debate
we had this cropped
up uh and um it cropped up every at
every hostage we went to ever since and
he and I get on very well uh but we
always debate this sort of thing and he
I debated it in the in the in the
lemonan Coura in on the 4th of October
2021 because he wrote a piece that said
Germany shows what's wrong with
proportional representation and I wrote
back and said Germany shows what's right
with proportional representation and the
interesting thing about this discussion
is not whether what's right or wrong
play on words intentional
it's and Council Harvey said this it's
about the outcomes well my view
is the outcome that's not really what D
it's not about what what what you want
it's what the people want it's about
democracy and what's correct and we if
we do settle on what the outcomes on and
various examples like Italy are
mentioned but if you talk about Germany
which the leader referred to in a moment
at the time this would debate took place
practical outcomes and instability was
mentioned dur it was at the time I I
change the figures now but during the
past 18 years Germany has had two
leaders then it was one the UK has had
five it's now seven Germany has had more
more gross domestic product less debt
per headed population better credit
ratings lower debt lower deficit lower
suicide rates lower unemployment half
the coid death rate
yeah whether what depends what they like
about the outcomes or not I you
know thank you councelor rock uh
councelor shenton please thank you very
much chairperson um it's interesting
we've we've we've heard a lot about the
positives of of PR um and uh very little
about the negatives
now just to balance it up um so that we
those listening and those here today can
can then make their own decision on this
one of the the the big arguments is
often put forward is that most systems
of PR dilute the constituency link
because you end up with big
constituencies with eight or nine
representatives and they could be from
all different parties who do you go
to
the other sorts of issues that come up
are it's easier for extremists to
Infiltrate The
System
and I've got to say that's quite flip
that's quite flip comment I thought you
were in favor of uh of democracy I mean
as far as extremists go we don't we
really don't want to encourage
extremists the far left the far right
that that with on small
votes there's also potential gridlock it
encourages as we've seen in other
countries weak governments that can't
make
decisions it's not always and this is a
number of eminent professors in this uh
in the studies I've been looking at have
said it's not always wise to
compromise because you need a strong
government and PR does not always do
that the method of deciding the seats is
quite complex there are many many
different formulas now first pass the
post is the easiest to understand one of
the big problems in most countries is
that the electorate do not understand
how that person was elected the formula
is there are so many different formulas
that it most people will be struggling
to understand what what on Earth uh
happened in that election so far from
giving stable government governments
that make decisions it actually can do
the opposite so whilst I'm not saying
that we shouldn't go down the route if
you like looking at
this I I I personally think there's a
lack of accountability sometimes with
the pr system and it's confusing to the
voter the first past to post system in
this country has worked well for a long
time thank you
chair thank you councilor shanton uh
councelor uh Holmes please I'll be very
very brief um first to imply that the
current voting systems provided a stable
government is utterly delusional um you
only have to look at the long string of
conservative Prime Ministers we we have
had in the last few years uh to further
imply that it keeps out extremist views
well I I suggest you go back and watch
some of the speeches given at the
Conservative Party
Conference um and you
say thank you councelors continuing uh
you say that it makes things more
complicated but help me understand this
the conservatives got 44% of the vote at
the last election but got 56% of the
seats I don't think your mass adds up um
and finally our local constituency link
certainly hasn't helped us here in stord
we had an we've had an absent MP who
hasn't served the the community has used
it as a safe seat for him to leverage
his own political opinions so there you
go thank you councelor Holmes uh
councelor Jenny fraggy please a second
uh excuse my cough
it's it's after coid so it's it's not
it's not active coid but it's a cough
it's left me
with um interesting debate um um I've
gone along with the democracy is the
worst form of government except for all
the others Churchill said this in 1947
not his original phrase uh the origins
of the aphorism are
unknown I've always gone along with this
until perhaps this century when
democracy seems to be under considerable
stress people losing confidence in their
governments in very turbulent times
first past the post has delivered us war
with Iraq with all the subsequent
Horrors all the marches all the
arguments in the house lobbying but the
elected dictatorship of the time ensured
that this nation nation made a fateful
step the infamous referendum carelessly
moved to resolve um internal problems
has caused real crisis in the nation and
whichever way you voted in The Advisory
referendum the elected dictatorship made
that referendum possible
the enforced Coalition which has been
mentioned decided by the electorate
rubbished by the media but in hindsight
gave a relatively stable period of
government so a bit of a break on the
majority partners and a bit of a break
on the majority Partners Wilder
ideas good stuff did happen on Mental
Health reinfor uh reformed Le League
tables pupil premium shared parental
lead amongst other actions not entirely
due to one party but that is the point
good think things come out of a re a
robust and I understand at the time
assertive debate debate around the
cabinet table where the votes
counted a criticism of PR it cannot take
decisions but it is better place to take
sound considered decisions when all the
V voices have a chance to be
heard and another criticism is that
small extreme groups can take hold more
easily I have no more than to say look
what's happening with our present
government a strength of first pass the
post is it that it delivers a local MP
with local links not always true we have
MPS actually sort of parachuted in which
don't have those local
links um but PR systems some PR systems
can deliver those local links it's
ironic we've already mentioned this that
the form of PR to prevent this um UK UK
civil servants were part of the group
who introduced voting reform to Germany
after the second world war to ensure
minority extremists could not get
elected look at what first past the PO
post has recently given us complete
control by only F 43% of the
vote by only 60% of those
inran apathy I would suggest first pass
the post has given us voter apathy
extreme politics anger and an apathetic
electorate but many positive actions
from the Coalition income tax cuts green
deal all and to improve our leaky our
energy leaky
homes the enforced Coalition gave five
years of relatively stable government
huge amount of fun dissing the junior
partner many residents on the doorstep
from All Views told me that they were
not uncomfortable with the Coalition at
the time and
since just a thought when countries are
facing ex exis existential threats such
as War what do they form a government of
national Unity form of PR perhaps where
everyone needs to be at the table so I
cannot accept that first pass the post
is the only way to provide stable
government and I suggest that looking at
the various forms of PR we have there a
preferable form of government which
allows people across the country to know
that their point of view is being
represented I like other people in the
room I've actually voted in every single
uh election since the age of 21 that's
my
age and I have never ever been
represented by anybody that reflects my
particular points of view thank
you thank you councelor fley councelor
hat would you have any further comments
some up before I go to the
vote thank you councelor hatch um right
councelor I will I have a seconder and I
I have a I have a proposer and I have a
seconder can I please see a show of
hands for all those in favor please make
it very obvious please to help out Mr
Buckland oops thank you for making that
not
OB uh thank you and um all those against
please
thank you and um any abstentions
please carried thank you very much that
is
carried right item number two please oh
would somebody please invite councelor
perella to re-enter the room
please thank
you
just thank you um right infrastructure
right this thank you counselors this
motion um once proposed and seconded can
will also be debated with the rules of
following the debate
um this motion please be be proposed by
councelor uh
coucher uh please
thank you thank you chair I think it's
very fitting that we have this noce of
motion at the end of our meeting today
uh when we've already talked I think
about uh particular problems that we've
got with infrastructure particularly in
shipston um I am criticized openly for
being far too political U by my
conservative uh opponents um but I make
no apology for that uh because uh we uh
in the liberal Democrat group and indeed
in the green group were elected on the
policy of changing things here in this
District the existing uh uh
Administration was conclusively
rejected um and much of that due to
their performance
previously the people of statford on aen
District have plac their trust in us to
make change
top of the list for many electors is the
issue of house building and it's
disconnect with the provision of
infrastructure many of us will have been
challenged on the doorstep as to why
children cannot be accommodated in local
schools why are we losing our hospital
beds where are the dentists providing
NHS
services and I won't go on about
transport because I'm sure we've all
heard heard those issues as
well the core strategy of this Authority
has been very facilitative in per
missing Housing Development and that
housing development has actually been
built at a higher rate that was even
proposed within that uh in that that
strategy as has already been stated in
relation to the state of our nation
here we've also got a very quickly
growing level of
population 11.8% in the last census
period and we're also proposed to have
another
10,685 people by the middle of
2028 despite this enormous growth that's
going on we have not generated enough
money from s 106 and 278 agreements to
tackle key infrastructure
issues what is clear is that however
many houses we build in this District we
will never deal with some of our key
strategic problems that we have
got this is not appreciated by
conservatives in particular who just
rail on about house building and ignore
the implications of what that actually
does the labor leader at his conference
also nearly fell into the same trap of
just saying bulldoze as many housing
through destroy the green belt if you
need to um and then almost as a lesser
thought said actually if you're going to
do that you do need to provide uh the
the infrastructure services to serve all
of that additional
development I want to tell you very
briefly about some of the uncontrolled
house building that's happened in my own
village in
wellsborne we've got a two for mry
primary school but this year uh many
local people couldn't get their child
into the local school even when they've
had siblings there largely because it is
over
subscribed we have a surgery in
wellsborne provided as a result of the
development that we have had it was
designed to serve 9,800 patients already
there are 13,000 registered there and
we're having to cope Now with an influx
of patients from upper lighthorn because
frankly we haven't got the
infrastructure that we need there uh to
to ride to ride with us as for transport
well I think all of us talk about in
terms of the problems that we've got um
with public transport with roads um in
in our
areas I propose this Nota motion today
because the electorate in Stratford
District want action as a district
council we cannot solve most of the
infrastructure issues however we can
ensure that that they are properly
advocated and that we tell people about
them and we influence as Council junor
has said our partners in terms of
delivery more the cap uh this is really
important in terms of our relations with
central government who frankly have
neglected Stratford District largely as
has already been said through the
inactivity of rmp and also because we've
not always been clear about precisely
what it is is that we require we now
need to make sure that we are doing that
advocacy to government very clearly
about what we need in particularly in
relation to Education Health and
transport more locally the County
Council also needs Clarity there and I'm
very pleased from what uh councilor
junit has said in terms of uh us already
uh having some influence there um
Professor
Stoten uh and um Council Denny I think
made the case alongside Dave passingham
for the issue in in relation to uh to to
shipston we have some major issues in
terms of National Health um uh proc
procurement here in ter terms of what
we're doing uh so we um we must uh move
uh this notice today so that we all get
behind uh actually ensuring cancel yes
sure ensure uh that we engage and we
deliver the infrastructure that is
needed for this particular District
thank you thank you counselor
um right and to second can I please
invite councelor Rock to Second this
motion
please yes thank you madam chair and I
reserve my right to speak at the end of
the debate thank you thank you Council
Ro do any other members wish to speak on
this please um councelor hatch
please um I'd like to add to the list of
INF structure water and sewage which
wasn't mentioned um in my ward we have
had 40 plus incidents of sewages in
gardens because of infrastructure from
new um buildings and we all know about
the issues in rivers and we want to help
our Rivers become
cleaner thank you councelor hatch uh
councelor pton
please thank you chairperson I'm going
to start by tell everybody I'm going to
vote for this uh motion okay because we
don't get enough
infrastructure however can coucher is a
political animal it's a well-worn
management Trope that is deeply
unimpressive just to blame the previous
guy um your current Deputy leader has
worked really closely prior to the
election around the South warshire local
plan which had two key Golden Threads
running through it climate change and
infrastructure every single local
Authority member in every Authority
knows that is a real uphill task to get
infrastructure we all buy that but
counselor cair one thing that I really
do think you should think about is
demonizing house building first of all
the growth in this district has been
around employment as well as housing
okay this is a growing economic area and
people need jobs and frankly the only
people who tell me we don't need houses
are people who've got houses so what
about your sons your daughters your
nieces your nephews your God
children yes we need the infrastructure
but not at the expense of demonizing the
development that we do need to allow for
people to have places they want to live
where they want to live so I would just
ask for a uh some consideration to think
about this in the round that the
infrastructure is not just because we're
driving housing we're driving employment
and to also think about the messaging
that you're sending that says that
housing is bad it's not people need
places to live they need the right
places to live they do need the right
infrastructure and you'll be supported
on policies through the new Lo local
plan to secure infrastructure because
this particular conservative counselor
has got a track record of been trying to
push for that
so I'm with you if that's what you're
going to try and do but don't just turn
around and say it's been an Open Door on
housing you know the tra you know the
facts of the matter and on Gaden the
money's there for the GP Pro GP surgery
as I understand it it's the NHS that's
not spending the money so I think that
sounds very familiar to what we had
earlier in the day so I'll support this
but let's just be realistic about the
hard choices we have in the future thank
you thank you councelor Pon councelor
Pella
please yeah I want to thank councelor um
CER and rock for bringing this motion
forward so infrastructure has been
treated uh as as an
afterthought uh by the previous
administration the dispersal policy of
the cor strategy has failed our Villages
and I've been standing here talking
about what has happened to wford donor
time and time again um and as councelor
Arch was was also uh uh referring to uh
my word as well has been has
suffered sewage flooding surface water
flooding
so even the when we build houses we're
not building the right sustainable uh
drainage that we need to not have this
flooding so I'm hoping that this will
you know we as the new Administration
can be much more um uh Force forceful
with developers to request ey quality uh
and multifunctional
Subs uh and and again uh you know the
increase in houses uh we were supposed
to have around 84 houses in the v in the
Parish of won we're now over 100 uh
sorry 200 which have been approved but
that has not been accompanied by uh a
infrastructure in you know up upgrading
infrastructure in drainage or even more
buses in fact in fact our bus service
has been reduced when the contract went
to uh state coach by the County Council
so we got an even less frequent bus
service uh and this has to stop and we
owe it to our residents that we uh make
our uh voice H we have and and just get
the right type of housing with the right
type of
infrastructure thank you councelor Pella
a councelor v
please I'd like to second that also um I
think we allow or have allowed in the
past uh housing to be built in in in
areas dangerously close to flooding
zones I really do think that we've got
to be stronger about how we look at this
because if the inevitable happens and it
happened in Germany and Li Libya
recently in the last six months where
the rainfall was so extreme that it
actually damage brid Bridges and and
towns very very quickly and that could
so easily happen here in Stratford
District so I really really um en
endorse this and I do think we ought to
as far as in infrastructure is concerned
seriously look at our policies around
flood zones thank
you thank you councelor Ral councelor
Curtis and then I'll be coming to you
councelor passingham you're on my list
thank you chair um I don't think anybody
is
demonizing house builders I mean
developers will take advantage of the
opportunities that are afforded to them
but and certainly when I was campaigning
on the doorstep and people were saying
oh you know libd you're against you're
against development we're not against
development but what we do need to see
and I'm sorry if I'm repeating something
that Council P together has said as well
we want to see the right development we
want to see the right homes in the right
places meeting local Demand with the
right infrastructure in place that's
what we're we're not
demonized it's it's it's not a binary
choice we don't have to demonize
developers on one hand saying saying
that we want the appropriate
infrastructure is not QED demonizing
developers I think and but I I I think I
think you make a very good point that we
we need to work together on this but
thank you thank you chair thank you
councelor Curtis councelor passingham
please
uh yeah we we do obviously need a lot
more infrastructure more hospitals more
schools uh more um more buses but
there's one important exception to that
and that's major road programs major
road programs destroy large parts of our
Countryside the environment the wildlife
they have massive carbon emission
effects and they encourage more more
cars which once again create more and
more carbon emissions and we need uh as
Council pton keeps telling us to make
difficult decisions and a difficult
decision would be to not support any
future proposals for the Southwest
relief Road and to support better uh
public transport more cycle routes and
better train
connections thank you uh councelor uh
councelor councelor Perry
please thank you
chairperson um I was extensively
involved with a former counselor for
wellsborne uh councelor Kendall on the
development of Hasting house Medical
Center together with the parish council
and we actually negotiated with the
developers and there was it was a very
difficult situation because we had to um
agree and and promote the fact that if
we agreed to 350 more houses in
wellsborne we would have a
state-of-the-art medical center in the
center of wellsborne now that wasn't
didn't go down well with a number of
counselors but we won and in fact all
the residents who were nearby who were
opposed the idea because they were
worried about losing a green space
the fact they now have a
state-of-the-art medical center on their
doorstep which is now being signaled as
as a as a primary example of how any
medical center should work but that did
come at the cost of an additional 350
houses so infrastructure can be done but
it was in that particular instance the
result of four three or four years of
hard
negotiating overcoming difficult
difficult situations and actually making
something happen and I can tell you
today if we hadn't had that 360 extra
houses we would have a serious Medical
Health situation in wellsborne which is
now supporting upper light horn um
what's going on at GH so infrastructure
is possible
but you need to negotiate you need to
work with your communities and by
working with communities you get the
right infrastructure in the right place
but decisions aren't easy and difficult
decisions at times bring the right
results and I'm fully in support of this
particular motion thank you chairperson
thank you uh councel um councelor rockus
seconder please uh thank you and thank
you be ready for that contribution uh uh
I think what be
said I welcome a lot of the things that
um uh Council pton has said but the
motion does not demonize house building
if you look at the words it doesn't say
that and police to say you're going to
support that and that's that's not what
we're calling for uh because I think
everybody here you know we acknowledge
that there's need in our communities for
development La development plans in
particular there for that so that the
growth that sustainable affordable in
the true me of the word and suitable for
the communities we serve we do have to
have that now whichever the two parties
end up running the country in the next
few
years we they're going to require us to
accommodate growth some might say
inflict Upon Us growth that comes from
the conations to the North in Coventry
and Birmingham um in fact the one thing
that's clear is lack of clarity because
Michael Gove has caused callused into
question the duty to cooperate we still
don't what that what that means and and
as uh uh the proposer mentioned the the
gray belt which is a term just invented
on the hoof at the conference when
nobody knows what that means but that's
been called into question uh a
monochrome version of the green belt uh
which is something Afflicted this and
you're you're a victim of that because
we've had this development concentrated
in one particular band across this
District but so we've got that demand to
meet we've just been looking at the
state of the district that's talking
about 10 a half thousand homes to to be
met in in those figures that are there
those of you that have been serving on
the south forare local plan it talks
about 800 homes a year to be
accommodated whatever we argue about
what those numbers should be it's going
to be a number that's going to be
difficult to
accommodate
but whatever the new medical targets
bring people want schools they want
doctors they want hospitals they want
care they want buses they might even
want a councel to look after them with
counselors who knows probably not B
anybody they might do um you just can't
provide those sort of things with the
present funding mechanisms and we've
talked about doctor surgeries in the
hospital as earlier on however
apparently we can afford a gigantic
white elephant of a railway without any
stations for those of us over in the
East we can't provide cycle tracks
Leisure facilities and enough roads for
commuter traffic that we didn't even
want in the first place water and sewage
is not even funded by any sensible
mechanism at all because it has to be
done backwards somehow through bills
that are done
afterwards the community INF
infrastructure Levy bids are always
government have made it worse with this
poor piece of legislation they put in
the government just does not get it so
we need government to wake up to the
inadequate of the present system this is
what this motion is all about and I
would urge you to support the motion
thank you very
much thank you councilor counc coucher
would you like to sum up with final
comments you're happy right then um we
have a proposal we have a second I will
now call for the vote all those in favor
of supporting this motion please raise
your
hands is that you know you know thank
you very much
K item 20 urgent
business um I have actually been given a
list of about 40 items we need to go
through all right I'm teasing it was
councelor pton who told me to do that H
Revenge was always going to be mine um
the next meeting please of the council
is scheduled take place on Monday the
11th of
November December
sorry uh there been no further business
I declare the council meeting
closed well done